Доброе утро всем. Это все, кто зашли сейчас, да? Я правильно понимаю?
Да, да.
Ага, хорошо. Всех приветствую. Привет всем.
Давайте тогда начнем.
Сейчас, как всегда, мы начинаем с того, что меня сегодня может мешать учиться и что мне поможет.
Добре, на все про все 10 хвилиночек.
Працюем о парах.
Далее все доеднуются.
И у нас тема про симбиозы.
Добре?
Тогда мне нужна помощь.
Нужно разбить на комнатки на 10 хвилин.
Добрый ранок!
Привет!
Я зашел просто в комнату, и там был я только.
Доброе утро.
Только я увидела вас, девчонку, и вы сразу вышли отсюда.
Я еще раз полезу?
Я за вас уже сижу.
Надо еще раз, может, туда зайти, если...
Давай, давай, я уже выдала посылание.
Доброе утро, я пока что слушатель.
Всех приветствую.
Привет, всех приветствую тоже.
Анастасия, вы в комнате с Юрием.
Только вы до него зашли, он вышел.
Теперь он зашел, вы вышли.
Снова вас перекидаю. Что с этой комнатой?
Давайте, мы пошли. Хорошо.
Ну давайте тут уже общаться.
А можно еще раз перекинуть в шестую еще раз?
А нет, а что, давайте тут уже говорить.
Так вот вы с двух и работаете, да, вот Анастасия с Юрием.
это какая-то карма Юрий я говорю давайте в общей комнате будем с Владой общаться и с Алиной
а сейчас все что заходят то тут будет такие у нас без LED они будут спостерегаться
так как у холодом в будущем а цена конкурент на позиция без лад будь да без лад отрабатываю
ким нато а можно перейти в шестую или куда вот скажите пожалуйста вот вы видите что вас
распределяет в одну ким нато то у вас весь час мая быть по слонечку снижая где одна цель и ким
комнаты сейчас я вас в другой просто перекину восьмую створю вам новую и у меня есть сверху
на телефоне не надо не надо будет другая комната все хорошо мы пошли туда да да
все сейчас надо освободиться я сейчас вернусь пойду возьму себе воды и буду
Юлия, Оксана,
отправляю вас в шестую комнату.
Юлия Спорошенко.
Юлия Петченко
также можно куда-то отправить,
я буду слушать.
Тоди с ними.
Анна, доброго рангу.
Всех приветствую, всех очень рада видеть.
Есть ли какие-то вопросы с прошлого раза?
Да, что интересного случилось в вашем жизни?
Чем вы особенно гордитесь за этот месяц?
Спасибо за такие хорошие вопросы, за то, как я отдыхаю.
Да? А что особенного выкликает в ваших...
Давайте поговорим сейчас про вас, а не про меня, хорошо?
Есть ли какие-то неособенные вопросы?
Вопросы к семинару. Юра, у меня есть к вам вопросы.
Что вы поняли в прошлый раз? Что для вас было самым важным на прошлой теме?
Я с прошлого семинара сделал целую уронку за день.
Вы меня вдохнули. Потому что эти вопросы, структуру этого теста на 25 вопросов,
которые вы дали, насколько он погрузил всех в эмоции,
Меня это так захватило, что я сразу сел, написал, у меня уже этот тест есть, как мой личный тест, да, ну типа вороночку.
Только трафик у меня не был, потому что пошел другим воронками заниматься.
Но вы прям вдохнули меня гораздо, очень сильно.
Правдоподобно и брехнея.
Доброе, я рада, я рада, что вам это понравилось.
Снежан, как стало, как жизнь?
Добрый день, Влада, привет всем.
Да, я касаюсь вообще последних двух семинаров.
они для меня в транзактном анализе стали най-най.
Вот прям най-най.
Да, вот почему для меня.
Я так думаю, что я там сама для себя,
почему я много почерпнула и поняла, да?
Потому что они в особое место приседают.
Вот, но они еще для меня такие очень прям информативные,
как чтобы работать с ними, с этими вопросами,
в основном с клиентами.
И они дают дополнительную информацию, в основном,
про то, почему же наши клиенты не действуют иногда.
Когда они берут на себя обязательства,
в коучинге, они же всегда выходят с действием, и часто они приходят, не сделала, не сделала,
не до конца, не хватило. И я прямо начала давать трошечки таких вопросов из той матрицы сценарной,
какие-то тесты, что-то такое, что-то сглыб, и становится более понятным для них,
становится более понятным для меня. И вот у меня такое вопрос, знаете, Влада,
Мы же не про коуч, мы же про настоящее, про будущее, а вот эти сценарии, матрицы, они про прошлое и про наше настоящее, ну ясно, что влияет на наше будущее.
Насколько, ну, наверное, этично и в рамках коучинговой профессии использовать вот эти знания.
Я вижу результат, я вижу, когда клиент понимает, ой, блин, а я же про это думал, действительно, а это же у меня там-то, там-то, вот он и видит какие-то паттерны поведения, да, и он готов что-то менять.
Но это вообще в межах коучинговой профессии?
Доброе, давайте вместе вернемся к реалиям жизни.
Реалии жизни очень простые.
Есть социальный уровень, там, где вы знаете,
что вы, как коучи, в этичных межах
должны работать только про теперешний час
и формировать будущее, да?
А теперь вернемся к реалиям жизни.
Минулое влияет на наш теперешний час?
Очень, поэтому и использовать сначала.
Единственное, что мы делаем, коучинг отличается от психотерапии,
что вы не работаете с состоянием регрессии.
Это понятно?
Конечно.
Консультанты, коучи, вы не работаете с регрессивными состояниями.
Вот и все, поэтому вы и работаете в меньших этических нормах.
То есть, если вы не возвращаете никого в регрессивный состояние,
как оно есть, вы же запытываетесь, конечно, у людей, а как ты, а что у тебя было в прошлом, да, это же бывает, так и есть.
И то, что я поняла, и это правда, людям нужно говорить, потому что когда они проговорят все то, что с ними произошло,
все то, что есть с ними сейчас, как им сложно, это основа нашей профессии, мы должны продолжать все чувства,
истории, которые есть в наших клиентах. И когда мы проговорим, сейчас вам намалюю очень интересную
такую схему. Смотрите, у любого человека, ну, представим, да, есть какая-то проблема и есть какой-то
состояние. Ну, так я, знаете, имбирное печенье сделаю. И эта проблема, она всегда находится в теле. Ну,
Например, я могу вас сейчас спросить, скажите, пожалуйста, что в кого-то неприятное произошло на прошлой неделе?
А где неприятные чувства у вас?
Снежан, буду на вашем примере.
И где-то тут, видите, я уже чувствую, где-то что-то малюю.
То есть, этот статус, он остается в цели.
Как ты его можешь избавиться?
Уявите себе, у меня не очень классно работает маркер, сейчас возьму другой.
Ага, у меня такая история.
Вот этот неприятный статус, или эта неприятная история,
уявите себе, помогите мне перевести, как нитки, клубок ниток.
Внутри, да?
И единственный шанс, ну, несколько вариантов, как мы можем этого избавиться.
Первое.
Проговорить.
То есть ты идешь с другой людьми, проговоришь все то, что с тобой происходит.
И она расплутывает этот клубочек.
Это понятно?
Таким образом, здесь становится меньше.
Ну, пришел кто-то и говорит, Снежана, у меня такая проблема, такая проблема, помоги мне.
И Снежана берет, это действительно основа нашей профессии,
если вы обслуживаете других людей, помогаете им как-то изменить их жизнь,
это расплутывать это все.
И тогда Снежана это все заплутала, расплутала, все это вышло из человека и стало спокойно.
Або, знаете, эти техники меднявые,
которые там пишут в инсте,
людина чувствует какие-то неприятные чувства
и начинает что делать?
Писать.
Также становится легче.
И осознание того, что с тобой происходит,
это 50% изменения людей.
Я дала ответ на ваши вопросы?
Больше, чем Влада, я очень благодарна. Для меня транзактный анализ стал просто честным. Я не знаю, каким-то дополнительным глубиной, с помощью транзактного анализа я смогла больше работать с клиентами. Я очень благодарна за ваши курсы и за вашу подачу. Я прям чувствую, насколько оно меня изменило, как коуча и меня, в принципе.
Я очень рада, что вам это нравится. Если честно, в транзакционном анализе есть также своя структура, да, учат транзакционный анализ людей в обучении, в психотерапии, в консультации и организации.
И для всех этих четырех сфер первый год обучения одинаковый.
Первый, второй год обучения одинаковый.
То есть, человек, который идет, например, работать в организации,
он так же проходит этот первый год, который проходите вы.
Человек, который идет в консультацию, это такие же коучи,
но они просто консультируют других людей.
Они так же проходят этот первый год.
И первые два года обучения, они как раз разработаны так, чтобы не вводить людей в состояние глубокой регрессии.
Только третий год, то есть школы психотерапии и транзакционного анализа уже начинают обучать студентов, как работать с этими регрессивными техниками.
А четвертый год, это психопатология, то есть то, что происходит с людьми, если у них есть какие-то очень глубинные проблемы,
или как нужно изменять клиента на очень глубинном уровне, когда ему плохо.
Поэтому первый год обучения я за него очень спокойна, он достаточно универсальный, у вас такие топовые темы, они интересные.
И я думаю, что никто у вас не впадет в агрессивный стан и не будет там ходить разъебранный.
Поэтому я спокойна с этим.
Но спасибо за вопросы.
Есть еще какие-то вопросы?
Что-то я поняла.
Да? Класс.
Слушайте, сегодня у нас, кстати, на конец нашего обучения
У нас осталось очень много таких интересных тем, и таких они крутые, они классные, они прикольные, я их сама обожаю.
Сегодня у нас прикольная тема, и, возможно, кто-то узнает, или там, ну, увидит себя в этих темах, да, и увидит свои отношения, отношения с вашими клиентами.
Эта тема называется «От пассивности до автономии».
Знаете, люди иногда бывают такие пассивные, да, вот как Снежана, как сейчас вы сказали.
Вот приходит клиент, и он говорит, что не хочет ничего делать, я не буду это делать, я не хочу, да,
потому что ему что-то зависит. Бывает же так?
Да, то есть бывают какие-то страхи, бывают какие-то ощущения.
Да, много бывает. Да, даже не клиентов.
Ты такой сидишь и думаешь, боже, что делать, что делать, как его, да,
вот этим пенделем отдать, чтобы он что-то сделал.
Потому что ты думаешь, что это, может быть, моя компетенция, что он ничего не хочет делать.
Ну, иногда так бывает, да, когда ты начинаешь работать с другими людьми.
Но мы сегодня будем говорить про такую тему пассивность.
То есть, когда люди не хотят ничего делать.
И как они используют эту пассивность для того, чтобы не достигать своих результатов.
На мой взгляд, это прикольно.
А еще мы будем говорить про то, как люди формуют симбиозы один с одним.
То есть такие объединения, такие объединяются. Знаете, вы знаете, что такое симбиоз? Кто еще знает? Рассказывайте, давайте.
Объединение, знаете, так что слова не могу сказать.
Да, объединение, объединение, такое себе.
Заради чего-то, заради чего-то.
Я думаю, что Снежана, заради чего-то, это не заради чего-то, это иногда такие паттерны поведения.
Короче, мы будем сегодня это все обучать, сейчас я вам покажу нашу программу, что мы будем делать, как мы будем, ну и вообще наш план действий.
Смотрите, значит вот так, пассивность – это поведение, за помощью которого человек уникает решение проблем.
снеоценяющая власть, способность думать, чувствовать или действовать эффективно.
Это все придумали шифы.
Очень классно они вообще эту тему развивали и очень классно они с ней работали.
Это был их топик.
И знаете, у них даже своя школа была.
Это была такая прикольная пара психотерапевтов.
И они очень классные вещи делали относительно усиленности.
Школа Котексису, и они рассматривали этот симбиоз.
Как вам эта история?
Вы видите человека, она не хочет ничего делать.
Почему она не хочет ничего делать?
Потому что она не ценит свою собственную силу,
она не ценит свои думки,
и она не хочет после этого ничего делать, и боится очень сильно.
Вот, напомните, пожалуйста, свою историю,
когда вы не хотели что-то делать.
Что именно вы оценивали в себе?
Когда не хотела работать с клиентами
на начале.
Когда начала еще, ну давно,
когда учиться, ну я еще не
работала, а когда уже от диплома
был, я
не чувствовала себя в силах, что я
могу работать с людьми,
как коуч, как помощник, профессия.
Мне всегда казалось, вот я не верила в себя.
Не верила в себя,
да, да, очень часто
Не оценивала себя, так оно и есть.
И давайте я вам расскажу, чем мы будем заниматься дальше на семинаре.
У нас такой сегодня план, смотрите.
Нам нужно понять, что есть такое пассивное поведение, что это вообще есть.
Далее, посмотреть, как люди воспринимают свет, и как это соединяется с сценарием.
Потом, очень интересная штука, перевозначение, порушение мысления.
То есть, как люди перевозначают какую-то информацию, то есть, говорят так, что они, как будто, уверены в том, что они действительно думают.
Поговорим про симбиозы, которые есть.
Ой, это такая интересная речь, вы увидите себя в отношениях с этими симбиозами.
Далее посмотрите, есть ли здоровые, есть ли не здоровые симбиозы.
Какие есть формы симбиоза и какие есть способы грандиозности и оценивания.
Хорошо?
Давайте сейчас вы подумаете и начнем работать.
Когда вам сложно или когда вы очень втомлены.
Как вы себя поводите.
Берете на себя за много.
Чекаете, что кто-то другой сделает что-то за вас.
Пытаетесь быть удобными или удобной.
Откладываете решения.
Много всего делаете, но без результата.
Взлюсь или резко реагируй.
Что-то выберите или это, или свое.
Второе вопрос. С чего обычно начинается эта поведенка?
То есть, как я или другая людина эту поведенку запускает?
Подумайте и вспомните какие-то истории, которые у вас были, которые повторяются, да, там, где есть вот эта поведенка.
Далее подумайте о том, что вы хотите понять про себя благодаря изучению этой темы.
Вы уже знаете, что есть такая пассивность, у вас есть какая-то поведенка особенная.
Что вы хотите понять и что вы хотите изменить.
И, как всегда, подумайте, пожалуйста, чем вы можете себя заважать.
Тут снова я вам дала навела
приклады. Мовчать,
снеценивать, вникать в прав,
ждать готовых решений.
И как вы себе будете помогать в этом?
И как вы себя порадуете
после конца этого,
закончения этого семинара?
Все как всегда.
Хорошо. Мне нужно,
чтобы сейчас разделили вас
на пары.
И вы быстро прошли за контрактом.
Потому что, что важно делать, когда ты начинаешь работать со своим клиентом?
Первое, какой шаг, какой шаг?
Влада, можете, пожалуйста, пока нас распределяют, еще первый слайд этот показать.
Я скрина не сделала, что мы должны говорить.
Я также. И первый, и второй.
Так, пожалуйста. Первый.
Момент, момент. И первый, пожалуйста, Влада, извините.
Закиньте меня в сомий зал.
Че, другий, че уже не сомий, там один я в сомому, я с
двух зумов заходил.
Все good, и ты в другий?
Не, не, зараз перекину в сомый.
Но в Семому никто к мне не подключился.
Нет, должны подключиться Юрий, Мария.
Так, а вы же уже в Семому?
Да, я хочу сверху выйти, там телефон, тут ноут.
Хорошо, если бы еще кто-то сюда подключился, было бы хорошо.
Так, Мария подключилась, нет, выше еще я.
Юрий должен подключиться.
Как вы?
Гарно, смачно.
Смачно, добре, идем дальше. Готовы, да, продолжать?
Смотрите, зачем нам это все изучать? Это мое наиболее любимое вопрос.
Потому что есть три типа.
Первый – симбиоз. Это когда мы что-то формуруем один с одним.
Неоценение, когда мы говорим, что вообще то, что ты говоришь,
или то, что нужно сделать, то неважно.
И так будут делать с вами ваши клиенты.
То есть они придут, они будут вас приглашать в этот симбиоз,
чтобы вы что-то сделали вместо них.
Потом, или будут оценивать, сказать, что вообще коучинг – это фигня.
И пассивность.
То есть сядут, будут сидеть и ничего не делать.
И это все есть в клиенте у нас.
Мы это делаем каждый день.
Будьте здоровы.
И это нормально.
Нам нужно понять, какой механизм включается в нас или в наших клиентов.
И дальше понять, что нам с этим делать.
Это интересно вам?
Вы согласны со мной, что такое выучить?
Заходит, да?
Чтобы знать, как сделать такой пуш для наших клиентов, чтобы он делал что-то дальше, а не сидел рядом с нами, дальше ничего не делал.
Смотрите, начнем с пассивного поведения.
Берн, он считал, что эта пассивность – это психопатология.
То есть это какой-то нездоровый процесс.
И он говорил, что эта пассивность возникает, когда есть проблема в каком-то его состоянии.
Скажите, пожалуйста, кто-то помнит такую штуку катексис?
Ага, типа немного помнит, да?
Вот мне неприятно это.
Я знаю, что она что-то немного... Катексис... Кто скажет, кто скажет? Скажите.
Ну, если я правильно помню, это, по-моему, когда один эгостан захватывает другой, да?
Нет, это контаминация, Оля, это тоже хорошо, это контаминация, это заражение, это вирус, да, вот когда одно захватило что-то другое, вирус там заразило, заболел, да, это называется загрязнением, контаминацией, Юль, да.
Это переход от одного эгостана в другой, да, если я правильно помню?
Перетекание психической энергии, то есть, понимаете, есть оно, например, протекание психической энергии, то есть, когда живется какой-то один из его состояний в человеке, а потом у нас заходит вот такой батько, батьковский стан, который говорит, что делать, вы должны это все сделать, я вам сказал, да, то есть, мы понимаем, что к нам заходит человек, в которого есть надлишок, надлишок в батьковском его состоянии.
Или заходит к нам такой рационализатор, говорит, так, сейчас мы обговорим, обговорим это вопрос, сейчас мы логично все решим. И оно также не работает, да, то есть подживление идет только у взрослого.
И вам с этой людьми, ну, так, знаете, как я говорю, сумно.
С первой части батьковского налякания, с взрослым это сумно, что-то оно так очень все структурное.
Або детская такая часть заходит к нам, да, вот такой подживленный, большой детский его стан,
который говорит, а я хочу это, а я хочу сегодня это.
Або я ничего не буду делать, потому что мне так сложно.
у меня депрессия, мне плохо, я сегодня не пил бы все кафе, я не хочу ничего делать, сделайте, пожалуйста, за меня, да, то есть это и есть катексис перетекания этой энергии, и мы понимаем, что в каждом из нас вас меняет 100% этой энергии, она как-то распределяется,
Джеки Шиф, эта мадам, которая начала изучать этот процесс пассивности, она разработала целую лекарственную модель, которая была ориентирована на работу с подростками.
То есть она начала работать с подростками, вот такая она чудово красивая, красивая женщина, и она лекарствовала людей от шизофрении.
Потому что она считала, что шизофрения – это набутая форма поведения своих родителей.
И вот она работала с шизофреническими процессами, рассматривала это все и думала, что есть неправильное выхование.
И она имела частковую рацию. И вот она подумала, что когда родители нездоровые, они формуют с своей дочерью нездоровый симбиоз.
То есть что-то делают вместо своей дочери, и она теряет силы.
Давайте я вам наведу сейчас какой-то пример.
Знаете, мемы сейчас в инсте ходят. Хлопцы, это не до вас, но я такое видела в инсте.
Сыночка-корзиночка, алло, алло, мама, добрый, знаешь, что делать, ты чего мне не звонишь, что ты сегодня оденешь?
Або когда нет мамы, иногда женщины подключаются к таких отношениям, и они уже выполняют эту роль, когда они все тянут на себя.
И тогда мужчина потеряет свою автономность, свою мускуленность, потому что она вся украдена, не имеет этой возможности.
Поэтому нужно понять, как вы вплываете на других людей.
Так, Василий, слушаю, слушаю. Какие вопросы?
Есть такой фильм, что мама кричит Мойшу домой, говорит Мойша домой, он говорит, мама, я замерз, или я голодный, скажи, почему я иду домой.
Да, вот это есть, Василий, спасибо, я никого не хочу обрадовать, но это формирование этого, ну, мужчины, они становятся пассивными, а мама формирует с ними, или женщина формирует с ними нездоровый симбиоз.
Иногда женщины говорят, что вот у меня, это то, что я вижу в психотерапии, ну такой ледащий, ну ничего не делает, ну я должен и работать, и готовить, и детей там с ними все делать, а вот он такой, вот такая зараза, такой поганец, ну такой поганец.
А почему так все произошло? Потому что когда-то в детстве были такие способы поведения делать саму родину этого мужчины. Мама делала все, или кто-то делал все. И человек привык ничего не делать.
Доброе, вопрос для вас. Скажите, пожалуйста, кто-то в своем жизни отказывается, если за него все делают, за него пекутся? Кто-то отказывается от этого? Я нет. Я лично нет.
У меня вопрос. Может быть такой вариант, что все-таки мама на сына наваливала дофига, он делал, но мама потом оценивала и сказала, что все равно все она делает. И будет тут ратить тот же сценарий?
Такой же, да. Я же не говорю, что и так бывает. Знаете, как мама, я сейчас гадаю такие психотерапевтические случаи, да, там,
человек, сын, я не знаю, там, 5-6 лет, приготовил яичник, принес маме на снеданок, показывает, мама, все, посмотри, как, ну, так я сделал, все так красиво, просто.
Она говорит, а чего желток весь, ну, не такой, как есть?
Ты что, это что, шкваринка?
Это что это? А булочка где?
Понимаете, про что я говорю?
И это такой паттерн поведения, когда потом уже людина думает,
с какой я должен готовить матусю, или кому-то какую-то яичницу,
или открывать свой бизнес, или достигать цели.
потому что все равно найдется кто-то, который знает, почему к мне можно придаваться.
И это очень часто такой процесс в коучинге, в психотерапии,
когда человек просто боится это делать, потому что он где-то у себя в голове
слышит без конца, что все будет плохо, у меня это не выйдет, я не смогу,
есть вот такие какие-то преграды.
И так оно происходит по жизни.
То есть вы вспомнили, что есть энергия катексиса.
Заджеки-шифт – это психическая энергия, которая перетекает с одного стана в другой.
То есть происходит такое катектование.
Такое интересное слово.
И что еще есть интересного?
У нас для того, чтобы мы были счастливыми, нам нужно рассмотреть такую триаду развития наших потреб.
Знаете, в целом, почему люди несчастные?
Я не говорю про травмы, детское прошлое.
Они содержат свои потребности, они чувствуют себя так, как они хотят.
Так, молодцы.
И поэтому нам нужно научиться и понять, как нам быть счастливым.
И это делается так.
Нужно сделать, понять, какая у меня потребность.
Перед этим просто осознавать, что она у меня есть, эта потребность.
И дальше нужно выражение сделать этой потребности другой человек.
Кстати, знаете, что мне нравится в транзакционном анализе?
Вот убожнюю это все.
Эту фразу, это мой топик.
Это мой топик. Записывайте за мной, это очень классная фраза.
Я вам позволяю, она мне понравится и вам понравится.
Аж от радости, знаете, меня захватило такое почувствие радости.
Значит, пишите.
В транзакционном анализе 100% собственных потребностей
должно быть на 100% озвучено.
Если ты этого не сделал, ты пассивный.
То есть, если у меня есть какая-то проблема,
шеф, у меня есть проблема, я про нее молчу.
Или есть какая-то моя потребность личная, что-то я хочу, очень хочу.
Но я про это молчу и не говорю другим людям.
Ну не знаю, может там у меня мама научила, она так меня не научила,
но я думаю, что если меня люди любят, то они должны отгадать все мои желания.
Это также, знаете, сказка, сказка, которую мужчины и женщины проговорят в отношениях.
Если ты не понимаешь, что я сейчас хочу, все, ты меня не любишь.
Это драма.
То есть нужно научиться проговаривать 100% своих потребностей другим людям.
Давайте сейчас вы над этой фразой подумайте.
Люди, подумайте, пожалуйста.
Чи вы проговариваете на 100% свои потребности,
чи щось вам заважает?
От цього и почнем.
Но все про все аж целых 5 минут,
потому что я думаю, что это изменит вашу поведенку
вообще на все жизнь, когда вы начнете
проговаривать свои потребности.
Но в транзакционном анализе
не означает, что все
100% ваших потребностей
будут удовлетворены.
То есть проговорить можно,
но будут ли они удовлетворены,
не факт.
На 5 минут.
Почему? Я не понимаю. А так, Ира, слушаю.
Доброе утро всем. Влада, правильно я понимаю, что если наши потребности 100% не удовлетворены, то, возможно, их можно отнести к желаниям?
То есть это наши желания, а не факт, что они являются нашей потребностью?
Воно може бути потребе, воно може бути бажаням, але нам потрібно зрозуміте для початку сказати іншій людіні, що я хочу, бо багато людей не говоріть взагалі, що я хочу, тим самым крадучи в себе радість, або живучи в очікуваннях, що, я не знаю, там, Ира, вы чи хтось інший буде різуміти, що я хочу. Ніхто цього не знає, крім мене. Так, Настя, кажи.
Для себя важен сам процесс, просто озвучить, не факт, что ты получишь, правильно?
Конечно, Настя, ну конечно, но никто не будет.
Озвучить, да, просто озвучить.
Да, и знаете, я всегда говорю, когда я озвучиваю своё желание или свою потребность,
ну тогда мяч уже на поле другого игрока, тогда уже ему надо что-то делать с моим желанием, да,
то есть пока я молчу, мяч у меня, я такая сижу, как лушим, маклуш, и такая,
мир ко мне не справедлив, люди не делают то, что я хочу, да,
но когда я уже сказала про этот голос, ну что, людина может что-то делать,
а я не буду что-то делать, а я смотрю на эту людину всегда и думаю,
боже, какая интересная история, что дальше будет, понимаешь, Настя?
Да, я понимаю, просто да, мяч иногда, ну кинул ты мяч, а тебя туда, фу-фу, твой мяч забери назад.
Настя, для чего озвучивать? Вопрос.
Это его персональная история.
Это да. Так а мне зачем?
Как зачем?
Может, для себя озвучивать тогда?
Нет, для себя озвучивать мысленно не работает.
С сегодняшнего дня мы вычёркиваем вот этот мысленный разговор
с самим собой, как с самым приятным человеком на Земле,
о том, а ты знаешь, что я хочу?
Знаешь, сидишь сама наедине с собой.
Но это классно поговорить, если ты понимаешь,
рядом возле тебя никого нет но можно прийти я не знаю там к возлюбленному кому-то еще и сказать а
ты знаешь что я хочу а дальше уже задача другого человека знаешь нас вот это называется вывод из
симбиоза стимулировать себя самого или не стимулировать и говорить блин у тебя мяч
сегодня зеленый вместо белого я жду белые а ты говоришь но вот такого желания ну вот он сегодня
белый играем белым он говорит нет белым не играю все свободен идем живем дальше да то есть я
озвучиваю другой человек обязательно как-то реагирует это самое главное саду же важного
Женщины, мужчины, мужчины тоже, потому что, если была такая мама, которая сказала, я ешня, то фе, вам нужно
иметь эту свою мускуленность, свою собственную силу, приходить и сказать, слушай, а у меня вот такое желание,
у меня, мое желание, оно такое, я так хочу. В общем, на пять минут, хорошо, на пять минут сейчас.
Схема терапии и транзакционный анализ
Я думаю, что схема терапии
это часть транзакционного анализа.
Моя терапия произошла в схеме терапии,
но там столько было внутренних детей,
родителей и взрослых, что сейчас в моей голове
такая каша, что я вот где-то
прямо мне интересно,
потому что там тоже внутренняя дитя,
тут внутренняя дитя, и чем они разносятся?
Ты знаешь, это
каждый направление
психотерапии, он
немножко по-разному рассматривает процессы
и все. Понимаешь,
транзакционный анализ, он больше идет
глубину, смотрят, что у тебя произошло, возвращаются к этой регрессии. КПТ, да, схемотерапия, они больше
работают по-другому, они больше анализируют то, что ты чувствуешь, то, что ты думаешь, то, что ты
чувствуешь и какая у тебя поведенка. И в основном идет изменение через думки твоей поведенки.
А транзакционный через сценарий?
А транзакционный идет через осознание сценария, через осознание твоих потреб и закрытие твоих потреб, которые у тебя есть.
И транзакционный, он формует твою автономность.
То есть, понимаешь, гемотерапия КПТ это поведение, думки туда-сюда.
А тут ты должен сделать, взрослеть в себе такого взрослого, чтобы ты мог спонтанно высказывать свои чувства.
Спонтанно. То есть не за протоколом, а у тебя сегодня вот такой состояние, и у тебя есть вот эта спонтанность, осознание, то есть то, чего ты хочешь в своем жизни.
Ты должен это осознать, то есть это более масштабно и более глубоко. Понимаешь?
И интимность, интимность, то есть ты должен строить с другими людьми, Василий, интимные, то есть близкие отношения, такие гуманистические, понимаешь, я не видела, что в КПТ, что в схеме терапии, в целом, рассматривается гуманизм, то есть формирование больше чего-то масштабного в отношениях, а есть больше, Василий, такой, знаешь, как анализ, что с тобой происходит.
Поэтому для меня ТА более гуманистический, более глубокий, иногда структурный, так, как нам нужно.
Но в этом есть этот вкус, знаешь, потому что тут есть изменения.
Смотри, сегодня ты, например, не просыпался, кавы не выпил, и ты снова возвращаешься к каким-то думам.
Но ты же не можешь заменить на всю жизнь свои мысли, которые у тебя там были, которые запускают этот внутренний диалог, а транзакционный анализ, он помогает изменить этот внутренний диалог на этапе формирования осознанности про себя, про себя, то есть ты про себя уже начинаешь что-то другое думать. Понимаешь?
Да, у меня в чём эррор. Получается, мой терапевт, как я анализирую, это мой самый первый терапевт, 2 года с ним не работал, он был достаточно холодный, и в принципе то, что ты говоришь про схемотерапию, то есть он дистанционный от клиентов, такого рапорта я мало чувствовал, скажем так, но я чётко, когда ты сейчас говоришь про потребы, мы точно работали над тем, какая моя потребность не удовлетворена, эмоции, что за этой эмоцией стоит, какая потребность за этой эмоцией не удовлетворена, и как её удовлетворить тут и теперь.
То есть это скорее всего был транзакционный, правильно?
Про потребы больше, чем про схемотерапию.
Слушай, ну, возможно, так.
Но я думаю, что тут, знаешь, в схеме это и есть схема.
А людина – это не схема, Василий.
Людина – это очень сложный механизм
с своими не только потребами,
но и с своими состояниями, с своими сценариями.
Знаешь, для меня транзакционный анализ –
это как будто ты, как книга.
а не книга-дети.
Да.
Потому что у меня такая сумма,
там же есть книга, которая называется
«Схема терапии», и там
«Батько-детина-дорослый»,
и там у тех детей
5-7 характеристик, дорослый,
критикующий, вымогливающий, ну, и терботливый,
и бла-бла-бла. Ну, они брали это все
Василию Стеамб,
да, потому что это новые
направления психотерапии.
Да, в 50-е
Эрик Бернс появился в 57-58 годах, в нем эта концепция.
Он очень, он подавал ее на психоанализе.
А далее это все уже, вот этот драматичный трикутник,
который используют при лечении зависимых, при лечении других людей.
Он с откуда взялся? С ТА.
Но никто не говорит, что это, говорят, Стивен Карпман.
Стивен Карпман такой офигенный дедушка, который это все разработал.
Он это разработал. И после этого пошли эти треугольники, эго-станы, которые все там используют.
Но основой для этих эго-станов был психоанализ.
Эрик Берн был не принят в психоанализе. Это такой очень интересный сценарий.
Мой друг свой, красавчик.
Выкинули его и сказали так.
Но Картман офигенный, Клодштайнер с этой теплотой, уже последователь, ученик Эрика Берна, он также такой тепленький.
Мне нравится ТА, он и структурный, и глубокий, и тепленький, и работает с психопатологией.
То есть ты можешь ликовать нарциссический расстройство личности,
межжевый, шизофрению, смотреть, что делать с людьми.
Спасибо, Василий. Хорошие вопросы. Лера, слушаю.
Мы сейчас общались по закрытию этих потреб и озвучивали какие-то потребности,
что тебе хочется. И у меня почему-то возникла думка,
Что нужно прямо давать покруковый алгоритм, как тебе хочется, чтобы эту потребность закрыли, потому что мне вспомнилась концепция, ну, любовь, типа, кто как проявляет, потому что для меня там потребность в поддержке, она может проявляться, ну, какими-то определенными кроками, а человек поддержку может давать по-своему, и тут уже будет какой-то мисконнект.
Ну, типа, даже вот этот мячик, который мы говорим, я передала, а человек его отбил, ну, умовно, не так, как-то, или что-то еще, и тогда потреба будет незакрытой. Правильно я понимаю?
Лер, она будет не той, что незакрытой, тебе откинули назад мяч, а ты говоришь, например, ой, спасибо, что откинул, для меня это было бы лучше вот так.
Потому что транзакционный анализ, он научит развивать в клиенте мета-АТА, да, это развитие автономии. Автономия – это осознанность себя и других, и чего я хочу.
И спонтанность, то есть, вот эта детская радость или детское реагирование, что я хочу, что со мной происходит, как я это хочу, и интимность, вот эта честность, Лер, вот так тебе кинули мяч, а ты так честно говоришь, да, потому что ты можешь и промолчать снова таки, и сказать, слушай, мне вот хотелось, чтобы ты меня этим мячом в обличье не бил.
Ну, я понимаю, что ты хочешь на меня произвести такое офигенное впечатление, что я должен попасть в обморок, но в обличье, пожалуйста, это не делай, да? И вот это есть с этой интимностью, то есть говорить как хорошо, так и плохо. Это понятно?
Да, да, это очень классно. Да, я говорю, научи меня. Научи меня, как это делать. Я не знаю, как ты хочешь, но научи меня сегодня это делать.
И вот эта схема, о которой я вам сегодня уже говорила в транзакционном анализе,
то есть 100 отпадков мы должны озвучивать и будем тогда счастливы от этого.
Хорошо?
Потому что мы этим самым уменьшаем риск пассивной поведения.
Давайте посмотрим, что такое пассивность.
Пассивность – это то, как люди не делают что-то или действуют неэффективно.
Знаете, вот эта история, вот я сделал что-то, что-то не нужно, сделал что-то по действию, как нужно.
Або человек сидит и она ожидает, что кто-то другой сделает для нее это все.
А иногда, знаете, есть такой же выслей, а ты чего ничего не делаешь?
Ну, как-то все света за меня это выозначит.
Как-то оно будет.
Как-то оно придет.
Что придет?
Я всегда спрашиваю, что должно придти за этот час?
Я не знаю, да?
Или ничего не делай, сядь и ждешь на берегу, пока проплывет труп твоего врага.
Ну, к этому я согласна, не нужно быть злыми людьми, с этим я согласна, тут можно ничего не делать, тут все свет решит.
Но относительно того, что я... Что ты ждешь? Не знаю.
У меня нет ресурсов, я не пила кавы, у меня сегодня такой состояние.
Все, начну все изменения только с понедельника.
Кто там худнется у нас, да, я сегодня ем,
в неделю я начну тортить так, чтобы меня уже занудило,
а в понедельник я уже фитнес-вумен, я бегаю, занимаюсь спортом.
Но этот понедельник, он никогда не остается.
То есть, вот это откладывание чего-то на завтра, это также пассивность.
Это понятно. Идем дальше.
То есть, азаджеки, шиф, пассивность, это как раз то, что мы откладываем,
как я вам сейчас навела пример,
или вообще ничего не делаем.
И джейлолом этой пассивности есть или наша зависимость,
или формирование симбиоза с другой людьми.
То есть, если я ничего не делаю,
то, может быть, у меня есть ожидание,
что прийдет кто-то и решит это за меня.
То есть, эта пассивность, она возникает
или из-за симбиоза, или есть какая-то зависимость.
И смотрите, какая есть структура пассивности,
как она вообще происходит, с чего она складывается, эта пассивность.
Четыре вещи.
Патологический симбиоз, то есть нездоровый симбиоз.
Далее, снецениння.
Тобто, не важно, все-все не будем мы робити.
Або, шо ты взагалі міш робити?
Ти шо, вже коучом стала?
Навчилася, так?
Розумна дуже.
Знову в субботу все женщины должны гулять со своими детьми, обслуговывать свои родины, а ты пошла учиться.
Да что ты, дурна, что ты, дурней, что учишься.
Школу закончили, добре, добре.
Або эта грандиозность, то есть перебишение, то вообще не проблема, которая у тебя есть, а уже такое взлякование.
То проблемище.
Вчитеся на курсе 10 или 11 месяцев.
Это аж 11 месяцев ты вычеркнула из своего життя.
Это так долго.
Требуется быть коучем за 2 месяца.
А он один учился в программе 2 месяца.
Коуч.
Чем тебе не программа?
Что ты выбрала это? Это есть вот эта комбинация ненависти и грандиозности, то есть преобладание проблемы или пассивность, как я вам уже сегодня сказала, ничего не делая.
Я не делаю, мне это не интересно и делать это все не буду. Вот такие элементы этой пассивности и этого ненависти.
Сейчас мы немножко об этом поговорим, как это происходит.
Смотрите, есть какие-то внешние проявления, которые возникают при этих всех типах поведения.
То есть иногда люди игнорируют проблему.
Иногда люди, они игнорируют, что эта проблема может быть решена.
Иногда они перебольшивают размер проблемы.
Иногда люди надетализуют эту проблему.
Ну, например, описывают проблему детально так.
Кстати, у вас были такие клиенты, которые приходили и начинали говорить, что они хотят достигнуть так детально, что ты уже не знаешь, какую каву выпить.
Потому что ты уже потерял связь с реальностью, связь с клиентом, связь со своим разумом, связь с реальностью вообще в этом мире.
А он еще тебе рассказывает, как он там что-то над детально,
стена белая, но не белая, но она с крапинкой.
Но эта крапинка была когда-то побудована еще его дедусем.
Но этот дедус, он жил когда-то в селе.
И ты уже не знаешь, где ты находишься.
Это над детализацией, таким процессом,
когда человек вообще не может сказать, что с ним происходит.
Она не даст вам конечного результата.
И еще до этого относится надузагальнение.
Ну, также, знаете, как я говорю, надузагальнение.
А полетели на Марс.
Слушайте, ну, это же нужно пробудовать план.
Это план.
То есть, узагальнение проблемы настолько неглубокое,
что оно уже формует отсутствие процесса.
Человек не может ничего сделать с этим дальше.
Да, потому что она не понимает, что ей делать,
потому что у нее все такое по легкам,
как я говорю так, как металлик.
А что у нас есть проблемы в жизни?
У нас нет проблем в жизни.
У нас цветы, у нас пони,
у нас единороги, мы сегодня летим на Марс.
Да, то есть такое надозрение.
Всё очень легко. Это вы поняли, как это всё происходит, как эти истории вообще есть?
И смотрите, когда это всё происходит, как оно происходит?
Оно часто происходит, например, за счёт транзакций. Кто помнит, что такое транзакция?
Ну, что-то я вижу, что-то там говорят, вот мне нравится, когда микрофоны выключены, да, значит, я очень разумно что-то говорю, да, стимулы реакции, так.
Это очень классно, действительно. Ну, то есть, наша коммуникация, привет, привет, я тебе привет, ты мне ответил, да.
И мы же в транзакционном анализе, он же так и называется, транзакционный анализ, да, то есть, мы весь час изучаем, что нам люди сказали,
и что мы им ответили, и как это все заблокировало нашу поведенку,
и почему мы это не делаем.
То есть есть такие два типа транзакций,
когда люди будут что-то отхилять или блокировать в разговоре с вами.
Это очень важно.
Есть три роли, которые будут возникать,
и мы уже об этом говорили, в драматическом трикутнике
«рятевник», «переследователь», «жертва».
И есть четыре типа пассивной поведенки, которую мы сегодня более детально рассмотрим.
То есть ничего не делая, нададаптация, надаждация и насилие.
Или бессилие.
Вот благодаря этому всему мы будем рассматривать эту пассивность.
То есть, как с нами люди общаются, в каких ролях мы бываем, когда с нами так общаемся и какая поведенка нам притоманна.
Скажите, сейчас у вас есть какие-то вопросы относительно того, что происходит, о чем я говорю?
Все понятно? У меня не вопрос, у меня полный рывок. Сегодня какие-то такие темы точково попадают, где прям у меня в середине, где я прям хочу включать камеру и эмоционально.
Ну, прям очень круто. Спасибо. Ну, хорошо. Главное, что в конце мы тебя собрали, а мы соберем, потому что у нас есть взрослые вопросы, мы задаем эти вопросы, все будет хорошо.
Добре, давайте тогда дальше, если вы все это поняли, вы мои разумнички, мы перейдем к пассивной поведенке.
Вот с ней посмотрим, какие основные формы пассивной поведенки.
Первая, про которую я вам уже сегодня сказала, это бессильная беспорядность.
Другая, ажитация.
Третья, нададаптация.
Да, да, слушаю.
Можете, пожалуйста, пояснить понятие ажитация,
чтобы я в первую очередь...
Сейчас, сейчас, сейчас я просто сначала покажу,
что мы будем изучать,
а потом так все расскажу,
что вы понимаете, что люди такое делают.
Просто занотуйте себе.
Нададаптация и четвертое, ничего не делая,
или насильство.
Знаете, насильство, это такие гнивливые люди,
агрессоры.
До речи, их можно отнести не только до токсиков,
а до этой пассивной поведенки.
И как это все происходит? Давайте поговорим об этом.
Я расскажу про это слово над ажитацией, чтобы вы его более понимали.
Смотрите, вы видели людей, которые мотушатся.
Вы видели, возможно, людину, если она в стрессе, она сидит и делает.
Або машет ногой.
Видели, да?
Дети так могут делать.
Они могут вернуться из школы, и вы можете видеть, как дитя стукает просто ногой.
То есть у нее есть нервовое напряжение, но когда ты спрашиваешь ребенка, а что с тобой?
Я ничего, мне не так нравится, я так расслабляюсь.
А что-то случилось? Нет, ничего не случилось. Это у меня там левая часть.
Ну ничего, ничего не случается.
То есть над ажитацией есть такая нервовая напряжение,
которая есть в теле другой людины.
Людина может трясать рукой, ногой, стучать, метушиться,
быть таким перезбудженным зато,
но держать себя и ничего не делать.
Давайте сейчас тогда сделаем такую большую упражнение.
Буквально на 10, на 8 минуточек. 10 то много. Подумайте, когда у вас есть какая-то проблема, какая-то проблема.
А что это? У меня уже открытие зала. Это нормально, я открыла случайно, все хорошо, закрыла назад. Ага, добрые, добрые люди.
Згадайте вашу проблему, будь-якую.
Ну, что вы там себе сегодня уже
сгадывали, да, несколько раз.
И подумайте, что вы
при этом делаете.
Ничего не делаете.
Нададаптуетесь под эту проблему.
Ажитуетесь, то есть
вот эта метушня. Або идете в агрессию,
или без силы.
И вам нужно
Но сейчас это всё же называют пассивностью.
И нужно закончить такую фразу.
Моя пассивность тут позволяет мне не...
Так, Аня, слушаю.
А у меня вопрос.
Аутоагрессия, она к какому относится типу?
Аутоагрессия, она сейчас не относится никуда.
Она больше относится к бессилию, Ань.
Потому что аутоагрессия, она остаётся в теле.
И в зависимости от того, что дальше делает другой человек,
Часто он не высказывает свои мысли.
А если он не высказывает свои мысли,
значит, он либо нададаптируется,
сильно адаптируется под других людей,
либо чувствует себя бессильным говорить что-то
или считает, что это неразумно.
Ну, я имею в виду, например, того же,
что нужно что-то решить, а ты не решаешь.
Всё время откладываешь, откладываешь, откладываешь,
а потом начинается аутоагрессия.
Ну, внутренний диалог, да, больше разрушающий это.
Да, но это больше тогда мы называем внутренним диалогом.
Аутоагрессия — это процесс агрессии, который больше вызывает уже психосоматические процессы,
когда ты чувствуешь дискомфорт в своём теле, как некие внутренние элементы напряжения.
И эти элементы напряжения в теле, они со временем формируют некий телесный сценарный каркас.
И аутоагрессия, как там она остаётся в теле или не остаётся в теле,
Она формируется от 3 до 6 лет, как стиль твоей жизни, в зависимости от родительских фигур.
Если можно было родителям возвращать всё то, что ты думаешь, тогда ты выплёскиваешь.
Это уже агрессия на других.
Помните, мы говорили когда-то с вами про аварийные люки?
Помните? Нет, люди?
Да? Доброе.
Вот это вбить себя, вбить другого, или уехать с разума, это вот таким элементом, либо эта агрессия остается в теле, либо она идет на другую людину, либо она вообще там уничтожает немного твои мысли.
Поэтому аутоагрессия здесь немного другой компонент.
Но это же тоже относится к пассивности, поэтому и хочется куда её распределить.
Ну, либо хотя бы в самом начале, то есть куда её распределить с этих четырёх направлений.
Аутоагрессия — это аутоагрессия, это другой механизм.
А здесь, если уж хочется её сюда привлечь, её можно отнести или над адаптацией,
то есть я адаптируюсь под другого человека, я же не знаю, что там происходит,
Или я настолько глубоко уже чувствую себя бессильным,
что не имею смысла, не вижу смысла об этом даже говорить.
На 8 хвалы, и потом у нас прерва.
Лада, а можно слайд практики?
Да, конечно, сейчас покажу.
Так, секунду.
Благодарю.
Пожалуйста.
А меня ещё распределите, пожалуйста.
Окошко пропало, я не могу его найти.
У меня со Светланой поставили.
у нее видно что-то, но я ее не слышу,
не вижу.
Вот.
Так, сейчас
заканчиваем кучки нот.
Вот.
Алина, как дела?
Все хорошо, как у вас дела?
Все хорошо.
Хорошо, я поставлю обман.
Что-что?
Я поставлю, чтобы было нормально видно, на коленках трамвала ноутбук.
Что там интернет есть, все есть? Да, вроде все хорошо. Такой тиждень какой-то шаленый просто, выходных немного выходит, но это так. Нормально, держимся, держимся.
Да, я вообще думаю, что все нормально. Я думала, что если не будет презентации, то я включу свою, которую я показываю своим учням.
Думаю, да ничего страшного, я как-то выкатываюсь.
Чтобы только было посылание, да?
Если нет посылания, то я же его не создаваю, я больше по Гугл Мидс работаю.
Думаю, ладно, такое жизнь, может что-то случилось, может что-то.
Я освобожняю.
Нет, презентацию доработали, дизайнер где-то доработал о второй час ночи,
а еще выгрузить, завантажить, это все, и я думаю, что с утра сделаю,
а утром перед лекцией у меня была встреча с Анастасией из нашего села.
Мы обговорили воркшоп, который будет в следующем тижне.
Возможно, слышали этот воркшоп-статус.
Нет, я не слышала, что там за воркшоп. Что-то важное, интересное.
Это триденний воркшоп, на котором будет подниматься тема
«Гроши, влады, энергии».
Это что-то на кшталт того, что Юлия делает «Гроши, секс, влады» в этом кемпе,
но в немного меньшем таком формате онлайн, и, кстати, студенты первого потока Юрий и Снежана,
они вести свои лекции первых двух дней, и на третий день уже Юлия будет выступать.
Ну, в целом круто, хорошо, пусть работают, молодцы.
Да, да, и мы говорили, ну, мы уже концепт как бы затвердили, все просто там по презентациям,
То есть я там и как маркетолог, и как методолог,
и оно немножечко
сложное в таких моментах.
Немножко поплющило
с этим процессом,
потому что много всего.
Да, и еще Юльчик
поехала в
пологовый.
Она же не родила?
Нет, еще нет.
Она, скажите, я скажу.
Тискная, может быть.
В ней, она захворела.
И так вышло, что она сказала, там в четверг, когда ехала, сказала,
меня могут покласть, чтобы я там в следующий день, в пятницу сдала анализы.
И если мне скажут, что там нужно лягать, то она, ну, как бы уже всё, там не залишится.
И вот она мне в четверг вечера пишет про то, что сказала залишиться.
Мы залишаемся, и до понедельника, как будто, должны сделать кесаревый рост.
Потому что уже час, ну, что-то такое, с того, что я поняла.
Но в любом случае, чтобы там не было, ну, как бы дитина это приоритет, и хотеть от нее какой-то работы, я думаю, это безлюдно максимально.
Я думаю, что это неразумно в целом, да, мы и не будем.
Вот, вот.
То так.
Да, у нас еще вот этот социатор из Швейцарии выступал, и мы, ну, так это все тоже спонтанно было.
Мы с ним и в вторник встретились.
Нет, в середину, да? Четверг был выступ. Мы встретились в середину, две часа. Я пыталась объяснить, как там Zoom использовать, как то, как все, потому что он там тоже больше по Google Meet, хотя он молодой, там сколько, 30-40 лет. Но это тоже было весело.
Классно. Какая тема была?
Психическое здоровье в бизнесе.
Это очень важная тема. И что он там?
Сказав, что есть много психопатологов в бизнесе, в верховке власти.
Ну, я могу сказать, что все-таки на мою субъективную думку
лекция немножечко была про психическое здоровье вообще человека.
Про то, как там держать себя, там про бизнес рассказывалось,
но это было мало.
Ну, то есть тема звучит громче, чем сама наполнение лекции.
так вышло вот ну и мы сделали эту маленькую такую google форму для опытования тоже вчера
отправила студентам то были и ответы про то что все же таки было много про... Я закрываю или вы закрываете?
Давайте. Было что? Опытывание какое? Было много про то, как работать с собой, ну со своими
и мы станем оперативной техникой.
Хорошо. Идем на отдых. На 10 минут. В 41 минуту встречаемся.
Кто пьет каву смешного?
Повертаемся, продолжаем далее.
Добре.
Начинаем рассмотреть более детально первый тип «ничего не делая».
То есть, человек, вместо того, чтобы использовать свою энергию на то,
чтобы достигнуть своей цели или развивать проблему,
Ее внутренняя, внутренняя дитина
использует эту энергию
для того, чтобы прекратить что-то делать.
Прикольно, да?
Ничего не делая, вместо того, чтобы взять энергию,
пойти и это все сделать,
внутренняя дитина использует энергию
для того, чтобы ничего,
вот прекратить себя, что-то делать.
И клиент чувствует себя как-то неудобно, но и чувствует себя, знаете, вот есть такое вопрос у клиента, ты его спрашиваешь, что ты думаешь, и он, я не знаю, я не знаю, я не понимаю, я не чувствую, да.
И он оценивает свою способность сделать что-то, ситуацию и вообще думать.
Подсознательно мы уже должны понимать, что наш клиент слишком напуган, чтобы о чем-то думать.
Знаете, есть такое чувство шока.
И наш клиент, когда он так говорит, он пытается создать с нами симбиоз.
Было ли у вас когда-то так, когда человек вам говорит, что он не знает, что делать?
Я не знаю, я не понимаю.
А вы такие, хоп, и погнали, и все, так я знаю.
Значит, план такой, план такой, план такой, план такой, да?
Есть такая история, да?
Добре.
Кто такие завзятые?
Я вижу, тут много посмехаются людей,
которые начинают уже становиться симбиоз,
и начинают же что-то делать,
когда человек говорит, что не знает, что делать.
А вы, а я знаю.
А я сейчас сделаю.
Смотрите, я для вас одну штуку нашла.
Лино, Лин, мне нужна помощь другая.
Да, да, да.
Я там в наш чат закинула одну такую интересную рекламу для тех, кто у нас очень, для взятых женщин и мужчин, которые есть в этой группе.
Что им нужно делать с такими клиентами, которые говорят, что я не могу ничего сделать, что им нужно сделать, чтобы вообще жизнь изменилась у этих клиентов.
Можете там закинуть нам, показать эту рекламу, пожалуйста.
Ну я закинула, попробовать транслировать вы хотите, чтобы я показала?
Так, так, так, очень хочу, чтобы вы ее транслировали.
Сейчас, раз секунду.
Давайте.
Для вот этих взятых женщин и мужчин, которые гоняются и делают что-то для других людей, это для вас.
Это у меня просто случайно, все свет такие, знаете, я тут раньше сижу, а наш учитель танцев,
он закинул мне такой смешной вариант рекламы.
Я думаю, ой, как дорочно, сейчас я покажу своим учням.
Потому что люди, которые все таки делают за других,
они такие всемогущие, как я говорю.
Они все хотят сделать, вместо того, чтобы просто успокоиться.
Выходит, Олен?
Спасибо, сын.
Сын, поднимешь мою палец?
Да, бабушка.
Хорошие мои коучи, вы поняли, что нужно делать, когда человек рядом с вами говорит, что я ничего не могу сделать?
Люди, пожалуйста, обратите на это внимание. Иногда с такими людьми, чтобы не вступать потом в симбиотические отношения, нужно просто ничего не делать.
Это для меня, это я вам даю такое, знаете, как домашнее задание.
Они говорят, вам будут сказать какие-то типовые фразы,
но вам нужно научиться сказать, что вы будете отдавать им власть назад в руки.
Они могут сказать, у меня нет думок, я не могу думать, ни о чем.
И вот эта власть, катексис, она находится в состоянии малюка.
И это мотив для других людей,
чтобы строить с нами этот симбиотический отношение.
То для вас важно сказать «Добре, добре, и я не знаю, что мы будем делать».
Знаете, иногда приходят к мне клиенты и я говорю,
«А что ты сегодня хочешь? Я не знаю».
Я говорю, «О, круто, я не знаю».
В смысле, как ты не знаешь? Я думала, что ты мне скажешь.
А я говорю, не знаю, это же моя думка, не твоя думка.
И ты так поступово начинаешь выводить клиента
из состояния ничего не делая до активности.
Говорю, ну посидим немного, отдохни, Машу.
У меня нет запаха, у меня нет работы.
Мне все равно, все же сплачено, все хорошо, можно отдохнуть.
А, ну у меня есть такой запах.
Ага, ну хорошо, давай тогда поговорим о твоем запахе.
Добре, добре.
Вот.
Сверхнададаптация.
Сейчас также покажу этот слайд.
То есть, так, Ира, так, слушаю.
Сейчас мне вспомнилось, есть стратегия выхования детей, читала, в Франции, что идет, как раз, нянечки,
особенно сейчас с телефонами, с СМС.
И в них то, чтобы довести человека до такого, что ничего не делают, что им просто нудно становится.
Потому что в момент, когда ты ничего не делаешь, ничего не занят, то они доводят детей до того, что им просто нудно.
И они тогда начинают что-то строить, что-то там создавать, реализовываться.
И это типа креативность вырабатывается.
Это сразу Влада напомнила мне, как детей хотят сейчас выховывать, чтобы без ничего, чтобы у них открывалось все с телефонами, это антителефоны, использование для родителей и так далее.
Это тоже такая стратегия, но уже для взрослых получается, чтобы довести, ну что, посидим, подумаем.
Я просто почувствовала, насколько даже на первых сессиях я боялась вот этой самой тишины, пустоты, как это так, я ничего не даю, она же пришла, мне же нужно отпахать.
Вот сессия, деньги, то, что было оплачено.
И тут как раз спасибо для рефлексии, достаточно классно, как оно работает.
Да, это очень хорошо, и мы сможем таким образом научить нашего клиента автономию.
И он будет потом, может, и изменивать это все.
Вторая штука такая нададаптация, да, або сверхадаптация.
То есть хорошее присоединение к любому ситуации.
Ира, это как вы сейчас сказали, мне же нужно подлажтоваться, мне же нужно отработать, мне же нужны деньги, то есть этот второй стиль поведения надо адаптировать, то есть подлажтование под что-то другое,
даже не спрашивая про их желания.
И человек сам не думает, что он вообще сейчас хочет.
Потому что и так научились, что люди сидят, люди молчат,
а ты должен к ним присоединиться.
И должен присоединиться к их целому, к их желаниям,
или сделать что-то за них, за этих людей.
Людина так делает, потому что вы ее родине от нее так ожидали.
И эта поведение выглядит как турботливое, как помогающее.
То есть я же сейчас подложусь, я же тебя так понимаю, я сейчас за тебя так все сделаю.
Но я иногда делаю не то, что меня попросят.
Все поняли?
Иногда я забираю этот пространство, эту тишину.
И человек, который надо адаптироваться, он также идет с эго-станом малюканой,
осознавая, что с ней происходит, не объясняя, что хотят другие люди,
но что-то делает вместо них.
И это не очень классно.
Потому что таким образом мы уже формируем симбиоз.
В первом случае клиент говорит «я не знаю, что мне делать».
То есть он стимулирует нас к этому симбиозу,
но когда мы на это отвечаем, говорим «я знаю, я сейчас все сделаю, я такая молодец, я все понимаю,
все, нужно, ты, что не запомнил, все, все, все, работаем, работаем, работаем, все, сегодня у нас коучинг, работа, все, собрались».
Мы нададаптувалися и мы уже захвачиваем эту людину в симбиотические отношения.
Ну, кстати, так очень легко по жизни, да, так можно посидеть, а за тебя все сделают.
Классно, да, и коучи там, и психотерапевты все.
Вот, следующая штука, вот эта нервозность, або это мотушня, да,
То есть, человек что-то делает, а поведение не имеет никакой цели.
То есть, что-то он делает.
Например, может стучать руку, грызть ноги, нитки.
И иногда даже эта нервозность может перейти в состояние, когда человек себя уничтожает.
И это также пассивное поведение.
То есть такая нервозность, вместо того, чтобы действовать,
человек держит себя, чтобы ничего не делать, она нервует.
Кстати, как вы себя, возможно, делаете нервозными?
Кто что делает себе?
А вы как клиенты ваши становитесь нервозными?
Я все делаю.
Ногами дергаю, руки грызу.
ногти грызут все самого детства я тебе привяжу но и у меня я сижу когда я думаю особенно вот там вся
настя надо было маму привязать они тебя ноги ну царство небесное зато сделала видите я из минуса
сделала плюс но я здесь ну а почему это происходит потому что человек сам себя запугивает внутренним
диалогом он себе устраивает больше сложностей и трудностей и больше при преувеличивает проблемы
поэтому нет выхода энергия ну наверное но из моей практики когда-то всегда было когда я высказывала
наоборот я была очень откровенно и очень или сквозь за это получала леща школе социуме ну
везде такой бунтарь вот и потом приходила и вот это все проживала внутренняя еще раз еще раз ты
Ты могла промолчать? Могла.
Почему не промолчала? Потому что, сука, нечестно.
Ну вот так. И всё, меня вот так всю.
Да, и вот получается, эта нервозность, она как раз и формируется через этот усиливающийся внутренний драматический диалог,
который говорит, а ты могла помолчать? А не помолчала.
Ну что ты сделаешь? Ну прошло время, ты не помолчала.
Да, ну потому что физически же получала, а не помолчала.
И так и не помолчала, получала и не молчала, получала и не молчала, получала и не молчала, но ничего меня не учит, знаете.
Да, да, да. Ну, в общем, есть вот этот стан над агитацией, ажитацией, да, вот это с украинского мова, над агитацией, это по-русски, или нервозность такая некоторая, добрая.
И следующий такой, жертвенность или насильство.
Также, кстати, очень классная штука.
Вот я это обожаю.
Также это слайд, это просто офигенно.
Смотрите, жертвенность или насильство, это также вид пассивной поведенки.
Когда человек, особенно с насильством,
вот занотуйте себе такими большими литерами.
Людина, которая абьюзивна, которая делает насильство над собой, а больше над собой это жертвенность, а над другими это агрессивность.
Людина, вместо того, чтобы изменить себя, она использует эту агрессию на других людей.
При жертвенности она драматизирует, а при физическом насильстве она начинает переследовать человека, который ни в чем не сделал ничего плохого своими словами.
И это является наибольшей формой пассивности. Агрессия – это наибольшая форма пассивности.
Вообще, вы когда-то так думали? Скажите круто, да, как глубоко, просто. Настя, что говоришь? Говори.
Ну, хорошо, а я, ну, например, когда у меня поднимается так на агрессия в одном,
я просто её в своё время стала перенаправлять в реализацию.
Ну, грубо говоря, себя загонять, то есть насильство над собой.
А, Настя, вот если бы ты пришла, взяла другого человека и сказала,
ах ты гад, ах ты гад, и начала его абьюзить без конца,
абьюзить, догонять, менять, да, то есть, и говорит,
вся проблема, зараза, только в тебе, только ты виноват во всех моих,
ты должен измениться ты должен что-то сделать это преследование вот этот тип агрессии вот такой вот
нездоровой знаете вот вспоминайте просто людей которые пришли тебя матом накрыли перекрыли что
то у них случилось не так и они просто догоняют тебя они вместо того чтобы изменить себя они
начинают без конца преследовать других людей я всегда говорю внутри но другой человек не
изменится но вот такой вот да зачем ты бегаешь его догоняешь работа над собой но смысл и проработать
нужно чтобы делать те кто нас бесит скидывались нам и мы шли в терапии они сделают а почему мы
свои желания могу мяча кинуть надо поле так все скинули смело отец ну красавица молодец
и очень красиво уже поняла доски сами пожалуйста на психотерапию нинча она не дешево стоит давай
и буду вас всех дженни отлично спокойствие зла гадит ну считаешь это да отлично нас быстро
разобрались с этим вопросом до агрессивного преследования ну вот и вот клиентов я клиента
вот то чем вы видите для себя понятие для клиента и он этого весь она есть он и направляет на себя
встала пошла работать включается 24 на 7 все реализации туда-сюда сейчас я вам как у меня
не-не-не-не-не-не-не-не если он говорит настя ах ты не делаешь то что я хочу это пассивность а
А если он, например, сел и говорит, я бессилен, это тоже пассивность, вот тогда получается, Настя, он агрессию направил на себя, сегодня был вопрос про аутоагрессию, то есть вот это ощущение тотального бессилия, да, я не знаю, что я могу сделать, я не понимаю, как мне это дали с тем самым.
маны бы сильно ну но если там один день два дня три дня да ну так бывает это жизнь до что-то
сегодня случилось это тяжелая а если у него это хронически тогда это уже форма пассивного
поведения понятно и да просто каша смешалось это и все и это не размешать надо кашу отдельно мухи
отдельно котлеты отдельно уже понятно понятно да хорошо так снижен туда таки питания агрессия
форма пассивности а вот это когда люди обожают что сказать что тоже форма пассивности за местами
чтобы сменять это выбираю обожал на кого ситуацию на поделить форма пассивности пассивной поведенки
Да, потому что образ — это не высказанный гнев.
Всё, с этим разобрались, молодцы.
И что происходит при бессилии?
Это вот, человек ничего не может сделать, и в ней такая, знаете, есть потеря деятельности.
То есть я бессильна, и у меня такое ощущение, что я с этим не вписываюсь.
И вот эта недеиздатность, то есть я не могу что-то сделать,
вонагородует в этом, и есть внутренняя думка человека,
я с этим не вписываюсь, я этого не выдерживаю при бессиле.
Так, так, добре, с этим разобрались.
Смотрите, какие есть направления этой агрессии или насилия, которые направлены на себя.
Сейчас я вам это покажу. Вы, наверное, уже это знаете, но, пожалуйста, смотрите.
Словояснить невербальные нападки на людей, майно или себя.
Далее. Истерика людей.
Такая, знаете, не по факту, а просто потому, что
людина сидит и она истерит.
Алкоголизм и наркомания.
Вот.
Смотрите, я вам привела это все к табличке.
Давайте ее сейчас разглянем.
Форма пассивной поведенки. Ничего не делаем.
Как думает человек? У меня нет думок, я не могу думать, мысление отсутствует или заблокировано.
Как человек себя чувствует?
Неприятные чувства, которые не осознаются и есть внутренняя напряженность.
Как человек это проявляет в поведенке?
Не реагирует на любые стимулы, сидит такая и ничего не делает.
Або задумывается, або отключается, а потом, я не знаю, что-то другое делает и остается пассивной.
И она створит симбиотический процесс, утримывает симбиоз, и энергия не идет на решение проблемы.
Нададаптация.
Людина думает о том, как удовлетворить другого, не думая, что ей нужно самому.
До речи, очень часто такие люди потом бывают несчастливыми, потому что они очень втомлены удовлетворять других людей, а себя не удовлетворяют, и если они себя не удовлетворяют, то потом они несчастливы, да, потому что они сгорели, выгорели, и так, Лера.
У меня сюда, Влад, вопрос. А есть какие-то, например, маркеры при взаимодействии с клиентами, чтобы можно было разъяснить, какие есть формы этой пассивной поведенки? И экологично это также с клиентом, да, проработать?
А вот это, Лера, как думает, как себя поводит, как почувствует, это все для клиента.
Ты ему просто подсвечиваешь и говоришь, что я вижу, что ты очень часто ничего не делаешь, ты мне очень часто говоришь, что у меня нет думок, я не знаю, что делать.
Я понимаю, что у тебя есть какие-то неприятные чувства, и ты чувствуешь напряг, может быть, ты наляканный.
Так? Так. То есть ты остаешься пассивным, потому что тебе мешает страх? Так.
Хорошо, давай посмотрим, как мы можем эту ситуацию исправить.
То есть что тебя поддерживает, какие у тебя есть ресурсы, как ты этим сможешь бороться.
И тут так же, да, например, ты видишь другую человеку, которая говорит, ой, я сделаю все за тебя, все за тебя, ну, как с этой рекламой, да, там, сделаю все за тебя.
Ага, смотри, а когда ты так делаешь, скажи, бывает так у других людей, что они рядом с тобой, потому что я вижу, что ты очень втомлена, они сидят и ничего не делают?
О, так бывает. А бывает так, что ты очень сердита или очень сердита от того, что твои партнеры по бизнесу или по семье, они ждут, пока ты за всех все решишь?
так было. Втомился? Втомился.
Тобто ты
очень часто подлаштовываешься
под желания других? Так.
Ну, слушай, я думаю,
что если ты дальше так будешь
делать, то будешь не оценивать
свои потребности, то будешь несчастливой,
как ты сейчас о этом мне говоришь.
У меня был такой клиент, да, который был
очень, ну, уже такой вынужденный.
Он говорит, сколько не приходит до своей
дружины, она все от меня ожидает.
Блин, даже футболку на день рождения
не может подарить. Да, ждет, что
сам что-то себе сделаю. Я такой несчастливый, Влад, у меня есть так много денег, но я такой несчастливый, да,
потому что я всегда не вижу, что я хочу. Я хочу и удовлетворяю желания только других людей. А почему
так произошло? Мама рано кинула, и парень начал удовлетворять желания других людей вместо того, чтобы
посмотреть на свои желания. Это его был способ выживания. Да, а я говорю, а смотри, какой ты интересный
симбиоз формуешь за своей дружиной она ничего не работает и ничего не будет и будет еще
больше в том льва тыс а то может даже и и можливей строчки проявить у себя доброе
дала бит по ветер на дякую так а ность а у меня такой вопрос может перетекать из одного в другое
ну в принципе все там несколько это чаще всего проявления чего-то одного или из ситуации человек
сегодня так завтра так или на одну и ту же ситуацию как вот это прожил все стадии сначала
погрыз ногти потом пошел всем все что-то сделал потом сказал вы все и сел такой весь жертву в
конце классный вопрос может быть по-разному да может быть и все стадия могут быть какие-то
топики любимая да может быть стадия в зависимости от того в какой сфере есть проблема потому что
например люди могут быть просто невероятно удачливыми предпринимателями зарабатывать
деньги все шик блеск все шикарно да там пушим достигаем результата а в отношениях новых систем
они работают она поломана да потому что если он в бизнесе достигает результата блин да я сказал
собрались и все пошли сделали все испуганы пошли это сделали принеси принесли ему прибыль но но
когда он придет с этой системы управления свои отношения скажу да я сказал пойди сделай дарма
женщина что скажет отвали то есть разных сферах даже может быть по-разному да как в семье делали
так вот делают и взрослые люди поэтому я всегда говорю мы можем работать здесь сейчас на прошлое
никто не отменял дала ответ на вопрос хорошо давайте отдавать это детали отцу туплый чудо
Додумаемся и далее пойдемте работать.
Ажитация, хаос, непродуктивная поведенка,
думает, но не может сосредоточиться,
вот эта нервозность, дискомфорт,
тревога, напряжение, уникновение глубоких чувств,
страх, провинция, гнев.
Вот это все, что чувствуется,
это и есть этими чувствами.
Постукивание пальцами, ходение,
туда-сюда, заикание, запинание,
курение, выпивка, бессоние, туда.
И энергия идет на поддержку, возбуждение, а не на решение проблемы.
Бессильство и насильство, я не могу ничего сделать, я не знаю,
думки размыты или отсутствуют, ощущение полной беспорядки,
потеря контроля и разряд энергии.
Смотрите, в бессильстве, в кого голова болит, люди, в кого там мигрени?
Сразу кто-то там оживился.
В кого есть мигрени?
Есть, да, мигрени?
Если есть мигрень, это про бессильство также.
Это не потому, что там что-то.
Это мигрень, ты имеешь, значит, законный статус ничего не делать.
Да, сейчас, Снежин.
И вот эта идея, знаете, мигрень, непритомность,
также людина там хоп и потеряла себе связок с реальностью.
Панические атаки или очень сильные агрессивные взрывы такие.
И это попытка навязать симбиоз другого человека.
И потребность, чтобы этот другой человек уже делал то, что ты хочешь.
То есть уничтожение ответственности. Вот так.
Так, Снежана, скажи.
Спасибо. Я так актуировала на мигрене. У меня клиентка.
Сейчас есть, которая имеет 2 детей, она живет в Нигдании, она расслаблена, у нее 2 сыночка, это подростки. Один подросток, один перед дочерью, что тоже не облегчает.
И она все, кто принято, тянет все сама на себе. И у нее сейчас начались очень сильные мигрени, прям такие, что до рвоты, до тошноты такой, вот это все.
И как раз вчера, или после вчера, я была с ней на сессии, и мы вышли на эту потребность в других,
что она сама, она не имеет того плеча разделить с кем.
Эти выклики в жизни, которые она носит, она имеет плечо для разрядки в плане подруги,
чтобы поговорить, чтобы принять эти эмоции какой-то с собой.
но она не имеет того плеча, с которым бы она могла разделить
те жизненные ситуации, в которых мы все находимся.
И может быть вот эта такая глубокая потребность,
которая уже довольно давно таки не удовлетворена,
выливаться уже в такую психосоматику, в такие мигрени,
которые она описала, что просто лягает уже.
Может быть, но мы всегда, первое, прибираем органику.
То есть, когда я начинаю анализировать мигрень с точки зрения психосоматического состояния или бессилия,
я всегда спрашиваю, есть ли какие-то органические повреждения, возможно, там есть смещение позвонков, еще что-то.
Да, органический процесс мигрени, она иногда связана с процессами эволюции также, да, то есть есть такой процесс, то есть нужно это все посмотреть, и я всегда даю такую правду, когда выникает мигрень, перед тем, как она выникла, нужно проанализировать, когда с органикой все хорошо, какие думки были до этого?
Негативный диалог, Снежана.
Какой негативный диалог?
То есть это помогает снизить напряжение в теле,
потому что у нее перед мигренью негативный диалог.
Она сама себя улыбается.
Сама себя улыбается.
И еще такая важная вопрос, я использую с возможностью.
Может быть, соединение этой органики, размещение каких-то там, плюс глубоко нежелательная потребность в других? Может быть, это тоже?
Да, да, да, да, да, да, да, да.
Ну, я рада, что вау. Давайте сейчас покажу, что есть здоровая адаптация к другим людям. Давайте, чтобы вы только не думали, что у нас патология, такие патологические процессы. Короче, смотрите.
Здорово – это когда мы думаем о своей цели, здорово – это когда мы реалистично оцениваем ситуацию, здорово – это когда мы по-справжнему запытываем других людей, что им нужно и как я им это могу дать, и мы удовлетворяем собственные желания и потребности, не уничтожая других людей.
Потому что когда ты пришел и пошел удовлетворять все свои желания,
а в тебе все плачут вокруг, это уже нездорово.
Такой сидишь, и меня научили, что нужно обосновываться про себя.
У меня здоровый нарциссизм.
Нет, это фигня, такого нет.
Это не правда, это не честно.
Так, чтобы люди не поруч с вами, они не потеряли себя.
Хорошо. Смотрите, как и почему это всё возникает.
Потому что мы по-разному воспринимаем мир.
И есть такое понимание светосвоения, то есть как я вижу этот мир.
Так, Василий, слушаю, скажи.
Где есть граница между этим нарциссизмом и людьми не против меня через нарциссизм,
И тем, что я начинаю
отбудовывать свои кордоны,
и те, кто по них юзали,
они же будут не то, чтобы плакать,
будут воевать, чтобы эти кордоны отбить.
Как тут взломать эту качественную
межу? Ну, типа,
ассертивность, скажем так,
может быть, это будет ответ, который мне пришла.
Но вот интересно с твоей стороны.
Удивиться просто, да,
в тебе так с всеми людьми.
Если с всеми людьми,
то, может,
то есть проблема. А если ты видишь,
например, своих людей, своих однодубцев, да, там, видишь, своих одногруппцев, да, они же с тобой имеют, ну,
похожие мысли, у вас одни ценности, одна группа, одно соединение, то, видишь, там ничего, как будто нормально, никто не
говорит, что ты пуговица, да, и как же, ну, там, образно говоря, да, и они говорят, блин, Василий, ты такой крутой, ты такой
говорит, ты чувак, так хорошо, классно, а ты идешь там до своего старого средневековья, тебе говорят, Василий, где ты, кто тебя перехрестил, повернись назад,
потому что так не можешь жить, люди так не живут, тебя плохо научили, все, остановись, ты думаешь, уже понимаешь, что у тебя что-то, ну, все хорошо,
если со своей командой у тебя все хорошо. Доброе? Спасибо, супер. Доброе. Вот. И смотрите, как можно
понять, какое восприятие света. Кстати, слушайте, всегда нужно понимать восприятие света наших
клиентов. Знаете почему? Потому что мы всегда живем с парадигмой, как будто они думают так, как мы. Давайте
я вам сейчас покажу очень интересную работу, пожалуйста, вот она, это как люди описывают комнату.
То есть давайте предположим, что мы стоим на улице, смотрим в окно и видим комнату.
Одна людина может сказать, я вижу маленькую комнату, она квадратная, в ней есть какие-то люди,
Там есть какой-то келемок, есть какие-то ферранточки и все.
А вы можете сказать, я вижу тут комнату, где есть родина.
И есть родина, в которой очень теплые, доброзычные отношения.
Я вижу маму, я вижу детей, они разговаривают.
И комната большая.
То есть нужно всегда с вашими клиентами
поревнивать объемы вашего светоспринятия.
Чтобы вы не сжиняли такое насыщение к своим клиентам.
Потому что, когда мы анализируем эти ответы, мы можем понять, что мы спостерегались за разными комнатами.
Но всегда подумайте над таким процессом, когда вы видите своего клиента.
Как вы описываете будь что.
Иногда попросите вашего клиента сделать любую работу.
Напиши комнату, да, или опиши стол.
И посмотрите, какие слова человек использует для описания.
Че вона мыслит?
Потому что иногда, если у вас у самих вот такой объем,
И вы придете к своему клиенту, или к человеку, или к женщине с таким вот объемом.
И вы будете, знаете, объем комнаты пытаться втиснуть в маленькую такую коробочку.
И у вас будет дисконнекшн с людьми.
Вы не будете понимать один одного.
Вы будете нададаптуваться и давать больше человеку, и она не будет с вами взрослеть.
Давайте на 6 минут, запитываете вы своих клиентов,
были ли у вас такие случаи, когда вы с вашим объемом
или перезаповнивали другую людину,
или втискивали ее,
потому что это уже форма пассивного поведения, как вы понимаете,
над адаптацией, над дежитацией, вот эти все штуки.
6 минут, по 3 минуты в каждую сторону.
Лада, пока нас распределяют, чтобы я разъяснила.
Это, например, если я там со своим объемом...
Снежанка, нужно сказать так, опиши мне любое.
Да, я поняла, но если я хочу свой объем запихнуть в нее, я в ней меньше,
то это у меня пассивная поведенка, потому что я выбираю неэффективную поведенку
Это же коучинговая как раз, когда мы ведем, радуемся, все рассказываем.
Нам нужно не рассказывать, нам нужно мотивировать.
Я же знаю, конечно.
Так, так, так, так, так, все. Только обеим.
Знаете, вы мне сегодня, пока нас снова, вы мне сегодня открыли Америку,
что пассивная поведенка, это также, когда мы делаем неэффективные действия.
Да.
Я раньше думала, что пассивное поведение, лягла и отдыхаю.
Я утрирую, но выявляется, что неэффективные действия, неэффективная транзакция.
Я думаю, сколько же я тогда пассивности проявляю, иногда, своим сыном, подлитком.
И так, и так, и так.
Я же не пассивная, я же такая активная.
Я же так ищу этот вариант такой транзакции, которая отгукнется в нем.
Где же там пассивность, скажи?
Ну, эту рекламу нужно посмотреть. Сыну нужно стать и есть, я не знаю, какую-то шоколадку.
И ждать, пока человек начнет что-то делать. Ну, а что я могу?
Давала все экзамены, не поступит 12-13 класс, профукает университет британский и так далее.
Я говорю, дети, я уже, мама уже научилась, а мама уже есть несколько обучений, с мамой все нормально, дети, то ваша ответственность, то завалится, ну что страшно, ну ничего страшного, она придет и на другую, ну что, такое жизнь, иногда так бывает.
Ну так бывает. И все такие активные стоят, потому что понимают, что мама не будет этого пенделя давать снова и снова.
И все, у меня нормально все выучилось. Я студентам так всегда говорю, я уже выучилась, у меня нормально, это я знаю.
Хотите учиться, не хотите, не учитесь. То есть я никогда не стимулирую, не тягну.
Хотите, делаем. Не хотите, не делаем. Все.
На 6 минут, давайте, швиденько, что-то там подумайте,
отрефлексуйте, выгружайте свои контейнеры и пойдем дальше.
Так, Йор.
У меня есть вопрос.
Давай, Йор, сюда.
Короче, как мы определили, да, как многие тут знают,
Мой стиль ведения сессий, он во многом построен на агрессии,
на пассивной агрессии, на хождении по рамках, на пихание непихуемое,
на расширение вот этого всего.
Вот, я бы так это определил.
И меня это прям драйвит.
Хорошо.
То есть там нету здравой какой-то штуки.
Я хотел бы от вас какую-то обратную связь, кстати, на это получить.
А какую, Йор?
Профессиональной точки зрения.
И тем не менее, как Эрик Бёрн, что-то своё, или лучше успокоиться,
или какие-то метринные выгоды, или что-то ещё, любой взгляд.
Такое посчитать не нужно.
Юр, ну, это же маточка зрения.
Самое главное, чтобы клиентам было окей, да, Юра?
Если есть такие клиенты, которые готовы вместить, например, больше, чем есть,
если они готовы к такой шоковой истории, окей.
но и надо быть тоже юра готовым до что есть некоторые клиенты которые вот когда ты вмещаешь
так много даешь так много они могут быть просто испуганная то раз потом могут ответить резко это
2 могут быть какие-то процессы это 3 мне кажется это очень индивидуально здесь вообще не имеет
никакого значения это может быть как стилем а может быть просто таким вот поведением которое
для кого то может быть не очень комильфо есть только что не интересно какие драйвером у меня
это запускает и почему вот у меня столько драйва в этом всем есть я слепой в этом ну где то вы
можете и такие неочевидные точки мне подсказать на которой я бы посмотрел юра когда очень много
страха мы такие становимся агрессивно внутреннего какого-то процесса до которые могут быть там
связанные с какими-то очень глубокими переживаниями до обычный человек он может себя слишком
перестимулировать когда этом кто-то его толкнул кто-то не принял он может обесценить свою боль
он может сказать а пофиг для меня вообще это не берет да и дальше вот на этом локомотиве на таком
паровозе идти вперед и говорит меня вообще это не ранит он такой типа сильный человек да и меня это
не смущает меня это не цепляет меня это не берет но разные процессы бывают и все по-разному я не
знаю я же мы сейчас не разбираемся с этим вопросом гипотетически я могу допустить что бывают разные
процесс может быть сижусь на кого-то да кстати сейчас будем говорить про светоспринятия там
как раз вот будет этот процесс почему я так себя веду хочешь давай давай если что интересно да
хорошо юль услуг погнали дальше с девчатами на практике вы накладки что питание что усведомления
Я сейчас про себя, например, скажу. У меня была думка, что пассивность – это бездействие, когда ты ничего не делаешь. А сейчас мы разбираем, что пассивность – это все. Это действия, которые не ведут к результату. Это бездействие, это агрессия. Я всегда думала, что агрессия – это активность.
такая не туда, но активность
в целом очень большая, да, там
много энергии, а выявляется, это
тоже пассивность. И меня очень сильно
прям зацепила вот эта разговор
перед практикой про сына, когда, ну, у меня
тоже почти подлиток, и хочется
как-то где-то его направить,
и мне кажется, что это даже и правильно,
но я не могу совсем есть шоколадку,
когда у него еще нет этого сформованного осознания,
что ему нужно учиться
и так далее. Ну, я не могу сказать, ну, не хочешь,
не учися. Ну, это моя такая
особая думка, и поэтому сейчас прям
Пока еще, как Катя сказала, у нас на практике эррор такой где-то есть, возможно, до конца нашего семинара.
Залежит все, Юля, от веку, да, например, то есть есть такой век, например, до подлитковой.
Это нормально, и даже в подлитковом возрасте запытать другую людину, а как, вот сидит людина, говорит, я не могу это сделать.
Ну, моё первое вопрос, там, например, я не могу завязывать шнурки. Ну, сын говорит. Ну, такая у него моторика, да, например.
Добре, а как я тебе могу, тебе помогти? Ну, завяжи мне шнурки. Нет, не буду. Чего?
покажу, я хочу тебя
научить, как это делать, да, например,
там, в 4 года, или в 3 года,
и ты учишься,
и ты учишься, учишься, учишься,
учишься, а, например,
человек говорит,
я не хочу это делать,
у меня депрессия, хорошо,
вопрос, как я могу тебе помочь,
то есть мы задаем такой вопрос,
как я могу тебе помочь,
но, Юля, действуем
исключительно
с этого вопроса,
Не больше и не меньше.
С взрослой людьми тут еще и понятно.
Например, у меня сыну 12 лет.
Он говорит, что не хочет учиться, не хочет учить уроки.
Я не могу сказать, что не хочешь, не учись.
Ну, то есть, и вот тут...
А чего оценку?
Это взрослый-взрослый, это...
Нет, а чего оценку ты не хочешь учить?
Ну, мне просто интересно.
Я всегда спрашиваю своих близких или своих клиентов.
Мне не интересно.
Хорошо, а я всегда спрашиваю дальше, а скажи, тебе не интересно, потому что учитель не интересно рассказывает, ты слова какие-то не понимаешь.
Ну, то есть, есть такой век, когда нам еще нужно Юлю пояснить, да, то есть, дитя, оно же не такая психика, как у нас, оно не может осознать.
Он говорит, да, учитель там подлюка какой-то, да, он такой абьюзивный.
Я говорю, ой, сына, блин, я тебя понимаю, а что ты хочешь, тебе нравится с этим учителем?
«Нет, хорошо, а чтобы тебе поддержать?»
«Ну, мне нужна твоя поддержка».
«Может, поговоришь с учителем?»
«Ну, говорю, хорошо, поговорю с учителем».
Да, ну, если я вижу, что действительно учитель там какой-то агрессивный довбань.
Можно так сказать?
Есть такие люди, да, есть такие, я всегда знаю,
что есть такое осознание, что в государственных или в некоторых школах учители – это садисты.
И очень мало мы можем найти таких гуманистических учителей,
которые могут там, ну, закликать, как-то привить эту любовь к своему предмету.
Або у детей говорит, а я не понимаю этот материал.
Хорошо, что ты не понимаешь?
Как ты не понимаешь? Нанять тебе репетитора, так?
Ну, то есть, такие, знаете, здоровые соединения.
Но если ты уже нанял репетитора, поговори с учителем.
А у детей говорит, а с какой я должен тут учиться?
Я вообще профессор всех галактик, и сейчас обучение никому не нужно.
Я говорю, ну, хорошо, ты учися.
И тут еще нужно выдержать.
Сидеть, попить чай, шоколадку съесть, или что-то съесть вкусное.
Нет, нет, Снежана.
В детском возрасте шоколадками нужно запастись, я так поняла.
Нет, нет, не нужно, не нужно есть шоколад, не нужно.
Это много сахара, нужно поесть что-то здоровое.
Мы уже взрослые женщины, нам нужно есть здоровую еду.
Да, мы не будем это делать.
Хорошо. Дала ответ?
Нет, Жанна, давай.
Может, я выдаю все, что до меня сегодня тяжело доходит,
но тем не меньше.
Давай запись.
Пассивность.
То, что неэффективно, неэффективные какие-то наши действия.
Я так, ну, и сидит мой сын, и вырешивает математику.
Раз неправильно вырешил, значит, неэффективно.
на третий раз ему получилось, а то что два раза он был пассивный, он же блин сидел и пыхтел.
Вот я как не могу, знаешь, это вот одно с другим. Нет, ты видишь, Снежан, если сенсив и неэффективные
действия, вместо того, чтобы решить математику, пошел и играет в танчики, то это неэффективное
поведение. То есть он должен делать математику. Если сын, нормальная дитя, села и делает ту математику,
и говорит, боже, сын, какой ты умный, первый раз не вышло. Так бывает, давай еще раз, смени что-то. Он
смены и переписав де я кажу сыну молодец крутые чувак я не пассивно поведенка пока
все это доброе супер нас давай но моего тоже убежал с комнаты услышал все это прошло что
домашки побежал прежде чем делать математику тут летает портфель стоит на меня и ненавижу
это учитель она короче он пока все стадии не пройдет открыть все стали отрицания гнев принять
потом он сядет пыль спусть пар спустится дитса делает эту математику ты все до этого он делать
неэффективно нет с послушайте до этого у ребенка есть свои чувства давайте немного сейчас разделе
разделить да мы родители здоровые родители здоровые родители должны уметь контейнировать
негативные чувства своих детей а как их контейнировать ну как мы выговариваю разрешаю
выговориться сына я вижу ты сердец да ты кинул портфель пожалуйста совете прошу только не портфель
не в меня не в сестру ни в кого накинул но так бывает эта жизнь достала училка до ваша там все
не было такая рыба а я тебе говорю ну представляешь только было учить и вот вот такая тоже и смотрите
познакомиться что тоже есть учитель ну и так может быть что будем делать разные но вот это
называется контейнированием чувств ребенка ну вот контейнировала объем вместила все живем дальше
хорошо да все то есть это эмоции проживать человека делать они тратят получается не
пассивная ну да пассивная того как сильно я сначала погуляю я сейчас еще зубы почти сейчас
этот обед сейчас я еще подождите пока как же вы еще писать водички налей потом только я пойду в
В 12 спать, но 6 есть еще.
Да, да.
Да, ну чувства, ну бывает, это школа, это жизнь.
Так, добре, идем дальше, да.
То есть, смотрите, вот это все, про что мы поговорили,
как смотреться в комнату, это называется свитосприйнятие.
То есть, как мы воспринимаем свет, как другие люди воспринимают этот свет.
И вот это свитосприйнятие в ТА, в транзакционном анализе,
называется рамкой воспринимания, да.
То есть это то, как мы видим что-то в этом мире и как другие люди видят что-то в этом мире.
И нам нужно это объединить, потому что через это восприятие света он фильтрует нашу реальность.
фильтрует, да, он действительно может ее фильтровать, я не знаю, если кто-то любит какую-то марку машин, кто-то любит какую-то, ну кому-то что-то нравится, какая-то машина.
Toyota, ну хай будет Toyota. Ну а ну ты любишь Toyota, ну ты вышла на улицу, у тебя фильтр реальности, ты уже видишь через свои окуляры все Toyota.
Такие есть, когда я хотела большую Тойоту, я только их видела.
Только их.
Это был капец.
У нас завезли, у меня только четвертая машина такая в городе.
Я их видела каждый день.
Я человеку показывала, завезли новую партию, дофига все ездят на том.
Ты видишь?
Это видишь, Снежинка?
А это означает, что у тебя фильтр реальности, у тебя такие окуляры.
Были, да.
Ты видела только ту Тойоту.
Теперь почти не вижу. Это не есть что-то специальное просто в нашем табу?
Да. То есть эта рамка, это восприятие света, это то, что ты видела, это то, как мы о этом думаем.
И это все пошло с того, как нас научили наши родители. То есть наши родители, они были теми, кто научил нас,
обозначающие люди, как нам
видеть этот мир.
И это все
складывается в наш сценарий.
И
когда я входжу в тот сценарий,
в свой сценарий,
то я игнорирую и
вижу свой мир через
свои окуляры
и могу не
решить проблему,
або
загнобливать себя,
або агрессировать на
людей. БО МЕНЕ ТАК НАВЧИЛИ БАТЬКИ ПРИЙМАТИ СВИТ. И я вот таке роблю. ВСЕ. ВСЕ. ЦЕ БЫЛА МОЯ СТРАТЕГИЯ
ВЫЖИВАННЯ У МОИЙ РОДИНИ. ЗАВДЯКИ ЦЕЙ СТРАТЕГИИ, ЮРА, ТЫ ЗМИХ ВЫЖИТИ. РОЗУМИЕШЬ? ЧИ ЦЕ ПОГАНО? НИ.
Нет. Если это сейчас никого не разрушает, ну что, так бывает, это хорошо.
Но мы уже становимся взрослыми, и нам нужно просто научиться разных стратегий.
Потому что это все формуется в детстве.
И наши родители нам показали, как действовать в этом мире.
Мы научились и начали это все делать.
Вот так.
Иногда, иногда, когда есть ситуация, которая нас очень напряжает, когда нам очень-очень сложно, подумайте, как про эту ситуацию, которая вас очень напряжает, вы же сегодня про целый день про это говорили, так, и говорим.
Вот это ваше восприятие света. Какое оно имеет голос? Кого из родителей? Кто больше вас был доминантным? Кто вас научил так воспринимать мир, либо быть пассивным, либо ничего не делать иногда, либо быть агрессивным? Что вы там себе выяснили?
Пожалуйста, сейчас поединяйтесь в пары и также на 6 секунд, очень быстро, да, чей это родной голос и действительно ли он, действительно ли таким есть свет.
Спасибо. Более-менее нормально?
Батьковские голосы слышали?
Да, Василий, скажи.
Хочу поделиться с пресс-судом, потому что, мне кажется, это интересный кейс.
Когда я понимаю, что эта ажиотация появилась через мамин паттерны,
но также это не выполнение основных целей, а выполнение второго ряда, это четко татовый защита от мамы и получается через маму агрессию я взял татовый сценарий, скажем так.
Потому что всегда я так думал, что все виновата мама, грубо говоря, а тут гопо выявляется у меня не было в кого что с этим взять, где-то прям интересно. Приплутал двух.
Ага, видишь, Василий, помнишь, мы иногда говорили, ну, там был у нас прошлый семинар, сейчас я объединяю, да, такая штука, как называется сценарная матрица, то есть, есть ты, такой молодец, и все в тебе очень прикольно, это прошлый раз мы, может быть, говорили про эту сценарную матрицу.
Она позже в прошлый раз. В прошлый раз я прогулялся, на сценарии матрицы я был.
Да, вот это видишь, то есть что-то тебе пришло и от датчика, и от мамы всегда.
Просто запомните, нам нужно, от кого это пришло,
понимать, и что оно сейчас работает.
Потому что нам нужно эту штуку осознать и прибрать.
И классно, у тебя уже видишь более взрослая позиция.
Ты понимаешь, что не только мама вина, а и датчик тоже был еще той героем.
Спасибо тебе за кейс.
Настя.
Я не могу сказать, что я что-то, ну, не могу быть, выявить прямой следствием, но есть такой как он сценарий, то есть мама поступала так, я делала по-другому, на зло.
Настюш, ну ты же у нас бунтующее дитя, да, по жизни, ты такая, я вопреки вам всем выживу, да, и я буду делать как могу, ну вот как Юра сегодня спрашивает, это нормально, это отлично, все отлично.
провело и конечно же из этих все как бы там ты не смотрел на это там как на трагичный роман ну
конечно же это дала вытяну как оптимист вытянул из этого максимум плюсов но так вот сказать что
от кого-то сейчас будет из этой семьи в кого ты такая ты не с нашей семьи сейчас подожди
подожди там есть еще немножко уточнения может быть то что то увидишь и тебе это откликнется
погружаемся то есть мы по нервничать да я тебя научу сейчас я вас научу да какая у родителей
была психопатология тут а вы заразу за миг реальные да и тем чином у батьки в буфу цепь
психопатологический процесс, и что
они вам передали.
Вот есть такое перевызначение,
и это приводит к
порушению мысления.
Как формуется это
перевызначение? То есть,
перевызначение – это переопределение.
Такое, ну, такое неимоверное
слово – перевызначение,
переопределение. Каким образом
это происходит? Как оно формируется?
Первое – с неценением.
Другое – грандиозностью.
Третье – развод мысления.
То есть люди используют перевызначение для того, чтобы поддерживать свои сценарии и ничего не изменивать.
То есть они переопределяют, перевозначают информацию относительно этого света.
В грандиозности они перебеждают проблему,
або переменьшают свои рисы, свои ресурсы, свои проспроможности,
или других, или ситуацию.
без манж еще слуха о чем-то девица грандиозность и
я пшу я там при меньшую свои реки сервисы отличается от значения
обесценивание проблемы нет а грандиозность это у тебя
офигенная проблема и нет ресурсов для ее решения
опять же вопрос джекпот можно сорвать сразу по трем правильно 3 3 и мы можем быть в джекпоте
и мы можем понимать что мы словили и мы можем страдать или переживать иногда потому что
родители нам это передали не со зла мы передали да ну и дальше надо разобраться что с этим делать
да и вот это нарушение мышления то что я вам уже сегодня говорила это когда человек он сверх
детализирует или сверх обобщают ситуацию и вот этапе рябца перевозначения в у нас
зажды и петре ему я сценарий будь якою людины то кто колы и людина перевозначает щось в ней
Нет, есть такие топовые фразы, топовые фразы после любой важной ситуации.
Она говорит так себе.
Это еще раз подтверждает, что...
Так и было понятно, что...
Это и есть все перевозначение.
Подумайте, как вы заканчиваете эти фразы.
И это будет вашим сценарным процессом.
Занотуйте себе, что вы там пишете, я не знаю.
Это еще раз подтверждает, что, например,
те люди, которые делают все за других,
они могут написать, что я там всегда один или одна.
Або никому не имеет дела до меня.
Або мне нужно всегда решать эти проблемы самостоятельно.
Занотуйте.
Так, говори, Юр.
У меня типа, я со всеми могу бороться.
Ну, моя история.
Ну, я думаю, знаешь, Юра, с многим правильно говорить, я могу очень многое решить.
Ты же не можешь поратиться или решить, например, процесс смерти.
Понимаешь, когда ты говоришь...
Я об этом еще не узнал.
Вот когда узнаю, тогда не смогу.
Ну, на самом деле, да, тебе надо тоже немножко,
но для себя это для тебя лучше.
То есть использовать эту фразу не все всегда,
или вот эту грандиозность.
Может, это и есть фраза «все всегда»,
иначе если наступит процесс, что ты совсем,
ну вот всё, ты вдруг не смог с этим справиться,
тогда, Юр, ты, может, почувствуешь огромное такое, знаешь, бессилие,
потому что в жизни бывают разные ситуации.
Вот если ты научишь себя говорить, я со многими ситуациями могу справиться,
ты будешь вообще крутой.
Хорошо, есть вопросы.
Есть моменты, когда я чувствую бессилие,
и именно с бессилием я ещё сильнее усиливаю этот паттерн поведения.
Типа я могу с этим справиться, то есть я отхожу от бессилия,
не братан мы с этим справимся я иду дальше я это моя движущая сила просто по жизни и чтобы я не
пробовал как бы заменить подставить вместо этого ничего сильнее я не нашел и каждый раз это
усиливаю поэтому понимаешь есть какие-то более выигрышные стратегии поэтому вот я дискутирую
по этому поводу так важно я думаю что это можешь сказать себе в этот момент слушает а нормально
даже в каких-то ситуациях чувствовать бессилие это не есть проблема потому что если ты говоришь
мы должны обязательно с этим справиться и орты игнорируешь чувства глубокие которые в тебе есть
понимаешь то есть но бывает такой процесс когда мы себя пушим вот нам тяжело тяжело а мы себя блин
вот без конца пушин здесь здесь не пушу да и просто как процесс мне происходит я не буду так
сейчас нужно отдохнуть братан давай отдыхаем восстанавливая чувствуем силу и когда я чувствую
внутри энергию есть все погнали разъебывать вот я понимаю тот меньше восстановление это очень важная
часть процесса в том числе даю себе время остановиться и погнали дальше и башки я думаю
что знаешь кроме того что ты восстанавливаешься очень важно мы будем на следующем семинаре
обсуждать тему как мы живем да то есть например у тебя очень много мыслей но у тебя не всегда
дать доступ к себе к своим чувствам у нас будет семинар про стиле поведения клиента дома то я
думаю что каждый из нас должен пройти этот семинар он о чем поможет каждому из нас лучше понимать как
хорошо взаимодействовать с клиентами с собой экспериментировать дадите в течение месяца
дайте мне какое-то здание пожалуйста но потом потом будет юра обязательно будет куча задания
у нас будет матрица обесценивания вот там будет у тебя куча работа она очень сложно но я думаю ты
разберешься хорошо конечно мы справим мы всегда справляемся ну большую часть времени так добрый
и дыма доля давить еще мы с вами робом а ну наприклад вы починаете сплаковато сезон еще
человеком, а она начинает, например, ты спрашиваешь другого человека, как ты себя чувствуешь, вот есть такая штука
первая, про то, что мы с вами говорили, отходящая транзакция, вы спрашиваете человека, как ты себя чувствуешь,
а другой человек тебе говорит, когда мы вчера говорили про что-то, мне было плохо, это что, это же отходящая
транзакция ваши были такие клиенты да наприклад там ты его сегодня запытаешь про то что
отбывается тут и зараз и он тебе говорит про что-то другое это называется отхиляющая транзакция вам
нужно снова человека переписать и спросить я немного по-другому я понимаю что это было вчера
да но например вот эта перепределяющая транзакция ее нужно вернуть клиенту потому что человек таким
образом, вместо того, чтобы решить свою проблему, она начинает рассуждать. Это понятно? Да, то есть она
начинает отвергать ваши вопросы. Нам нужно ее к этому снова привлекать. Например, ты
спрашиваешь, кто это сделал? Это отвергающая транзакция. Человек говорит, да, это произошло там до обеда. Я же
Я же не спрашиваю, кто это сделал. Я же не спрашиваю, когда это произошло.
Или ты это сделаешь? Ну, у другого человека, да, в коучинге мы можем сказать,
ты будешь это делать? Я когда-нибудь смогу на какой-то там с понедельника.
Стоп! Скажи мне, ты будешь это делать или не будешь это делать?
То есть нам нужно людей, которые отхиляют наши транзакции, вернуть снова в реализацию жизни.
Або что ты собираешься делать с этого привода?
Ну, очень часто мы там запытываем клиентов, а клиент начинает говорить,
о, я уже много раз это делал, ничего не произошло.
Або ты говоришь клиенту, ты должен сделать это.
Ну, там, помыть что-то, сделать что-то, сделать домашнее.
Он говорит, а я не хочу делать домашнюю, я хочу выпить каву.
Это все, если это происходит в вашей жизни или с вашими клиентами, это пример отхиляющей транзакции.
Нам нужно это помечать и нам нужно это вернуть.
А ну-ка, вспомните, люди добрые, кто вам так отхиляет транзакцию?
Знаете, я иногда говорю, ты им за здравие, а они тебе за упокой. Да, Олен, скажи.
В расстановках клиенты, когда их пытаешь про ощущения, они тебе думки начинают рассказывать.
Прям вообще.
Вообще, да.
На 95% постельно так идет.
Так, так, так.
Потому что мы будем это изучать на следующем семинаре, то не их, ну, я таки, разумение, да, двери контакта.
То не их двери контакта.
Они так не думают.
Вот такие штуки. То есть вам нужно понимать эти транзакции, вернуть людей снова к тому, что они должны делать. Это очень важно.
Або есть такое блокирование, ну такая же, как и отхиляющая транзакция, ты спрашиваешь человека, как ты себя чувствуешь, а человек может сказать, вы имеете какой-то состояние на уме, какой-то состояние, мой эмоциональный или мой физический.
То есть нам нужно понимать, что люди таким образом, вместо того, чтобы решать какие-то проблемы, они начинают блокировать нас и себя этими действиями, этими отхилениями, этими транзакциями.
И вам нужно быть готовым к тому, что у вас будут клиенты, которые будут блокировать и отхилять ваши транзакции. Давайте играем сейчас игру.
Клиент и коуч.
Уявите себе, пожалуйста, такую вправду.
Вот она.
Один что-то предлагает делать,
а другой без конца отхиляет эти транзакции или их блокирует.
И вам нужно, когда вы в роли коуча, сначала снять, какие у вас ощущения, когда вас всегда отхиляют.
И подумать о том, что это соединяется с теми ощущениями, которые были в вашей семье. Например, вам сумно, вам гневно, что с вами произошло.
и подумать о том, как кто-то когда-то реагировал в вашей семье на ваши предложения.
То есть посмотреть, как это связано и с вашим жизнью, как это связано с вашей работой,
и как это снова вернулось к вашему прошлому.
У нас все про все. Давайте в парах, а не в трех, чтобы очень быстро это сделать.
На 8 минут. По 4 минуты.
Пока распределяет, дай, пожалуйста, презентацию, я скрин сделаю.
Давай, давай, делай презентацию, но тут не троечка, а тут двоечка, да, то есть один предлагает что-то, а другой без конца дает вот это отхиление или блокирование, а тебе нужно следить за тем, что ты чувствуешь, что это связано с твоим прошлым и как оно связано.
Вот так. Разумею? 8 минуточек.
Трошки запизнемось на перерву.
Трошки.
Но потом мы ее трошки продолжим.
Давайте, я вас чекаю.
Доброе.
Как вы в Сахараст?
Так, Настя, скажи, говори.
Я для себя уснила, что, например, в семье,
там, где через чувства идешь, чувства проявляешь.
Нет, ну, как бы мне все равно через действие.
А через действие обращали, получается, внимание.
И чтобы выжить в той или иной среде семьи, нужно было проявить действие.
Действие радость, например, если базовые чувства взять, да, 4, через радость.
Ну, мне радостно, я счастливо вступила в лужу, попрыгала, ну, для примера, да.
Ну, то там прилетало через то действие, ну, как бы, обращали внимание, да, не суть, обращали.
Переодевали, типа, уже не умерла, уже хорошо.
Еще и накормили потом через леща, ну, нормально.
А через, получается, бунтарство, через гнев, да, то есть всё равно на тебя уже обращали внимание, всё, значит, обратили внимание, ты уже, ну, как бы, всё, можешь выжить.
А через чувство, мне радостно, и все такие порадовались за меня, или там мне грустно, и все такие, ну, давай погрызть им вместе, ну, никто не обращал на это внимания.
Да, да, это очень классно, и мы на следующем семинаре прям поговорим.
Действия, да, через действия, пассивность тоже, да, через действия какие-то.
Получается, ты призывал так какие-то, ну, через чувства никак призывать ты не мог.
Ну, у нас есть разные двери входа, мы будем об этом говорить, да,
разные типы поведения.
Очень классный семинар, его прям Юля попросила вам поставить,
потому что она считает его самым топовым, самым необходимым.
В следующий раз поговорим.
Хорошо. Так, смотрите, в 16 минут.
Зараз 16 минут плюс 20 минут.
Давайте в 36 повернемся, и будем говорить про симбиоз.
Повертаемся.
Повертаемся и продолжим.
На этом этапе, есть ли какие-то вопросы?
Чи все зрозуміло, чи не зрозуміло?
Якщо підсумувати,
є пасивні форми поведінки,
які були вивчені
з батьківських родинних форм поведінки.
Ми їх взяли
і далі використовуємо у цьому житті.
И это приводит к формированию пассивности в отношениях с другими людьми.
Сейчас все понятно, более-менее, или нет?
Такое себе, да? Что там, Настя? Более-менее нормально?
Да, ну, хорошо. Переходим сейчас к теме, которая очень сильно связана с этой пассивностью.
Вы уже поняли, если человек что-то не делает, то что она тогда предлагает вам? Мы уже сегодня про это весь день говорили. Она влечет вас в симбиоз.
Если она ничего не делает, то человек начинает формировать с вами симбиоз. Будем мы сейчас изучать, что такое симбиоз.
Симбиоз – это отношения или отношения, когда в них двое или больше людей,
поводятся так, как будто они становятся только одной целой людьми.
Людей может быть двое, может быть несколько, но ощущение, что тут только один живой организм.
И если посмотреть на это с точки зрения структурной модели его стандартов,
есть, например, одна людина, она использует родственный и взрослый его стандарт, да?
Такая, я решала вас, сейчас все решу, все твои проблемы решу.
но свой статус маленького не использует,
а другая людина такая, о боже, я же не знаю, что делать,
боже, как мне тут выжить в этом жизни, боже,
дочери, девочки, что же мы будем делать дальше?
И как же мы впораем с этой ситуацией?
То есть есть другая людина, которая совсем блокирует эти станы,
родственники, взрослого, и впадает в такой, знаете, в статус жертвы.
И таким образом начинают формироваться симбиозы, симбиотические отношения.
Почему так происходит?
Знаете, есть на самом деле нормальный и здоровый тип симбиоза.
Когда родилась дитя, она же не может сама себя обслуживать.
Не может.
Она же не может сама себя, дитина, нагодовать, заколесать.
Это же здоровый симбиоз, да?
То есть у дитины нет этого родственного и взрослого состояния.
Это называется здоровый симбиоз, когда кто-то другой, в этом случае Матуся,
она должна взять и научить дитину, турбующую про нее, доглядающую ее.
То есть дитинка сама не существует.
И в процессе развития ребенок учится сама думать, сама деться, сама как-то удовлетворять свои потребности.
И это процесс такой откровения.
Но негативный тип симбиоза сохраняется тогда, когда дети становятся взрослыми,
но не могут думать, пиклуваться про себя самостоятельно.
Згадайте, будь ласка, будь каких там людей
из своего отточения,
там, где мама сказала,
або
«Батьки мне заборонили ехать
там до сестры, потому что
в тебе, дитонька,
тебе 40 лет, разрядженный
телефон». Это же симбиоз?
Дорослая
женщина хочет ехать до своей
сестры в гости,
а батьки говорят, мы тебе не благословляем
ехать к своей сестре в гости,
потому что у тебя сегодня не было света,
разрядлен телефон, и что же ты, дитячка,
что с тобой будет? Ты будешь на
зубинке, тебе какое-то маньячило
вкрадет, что-то случится,
дитячка моя, не езжай к сестре.
Загадайте, пожалуйста,
какие-то свои собственные примеры,
там, где люди начинали
формировать с вами
вот этот нездоровый симбиоз.
Чего у вас все доброе?
Терпи, здоровья, симбиоз.
Так, Настя, ну давай.
Ну, когда мне было 15 лет,
и моя мама говорила,
боже, что ж мы будем дальше делать?
В смысле, Настенька,
что тут такое? Я даже стесняюсь спросить.
В 15 лет делала, что они говорили,
что мы будем дальше делать.
А, как жить без тебя будем, да?
Нет, нет, нет.
Ситуация была такая, что
я уже жила отдельно,
И я просто приехала в один прекрасный день,
забрала маму от отчима,
потому что там было невозможно.
Там уже опасность была жизни.
И вот она сидела, и я ее забрала к себе.
И она сидела и говорила,
что же мы дальше будем делать.
А, да, тоже классный пример.
Спасибо, Настя.
Прям реально хороший пример.
Я говорю, да.
Я сказала, лучше с голоду умереть, чем вот так вот.
И я говорю, еще никто не умирал,
так что разберемся по ходу.
Ну, как-то так.
И так я стала на долгие два года
мамой своей мамы мужем мамой мамой своей мамы всем чем хочешь да так вот это бывает хороший
кстати очень хороший пример да то есть очень классный на спасибо прям действительно тоже
такой нездоровый элемент симбиоза но смотрите нам же надо сейчас разобраться как этот симбиоз
возникает и почему он происходит. В том симбиозе, когда я вам начала показывать, может вы
вот так сейчас вам напоминаю, да, есть некоторые состояния, которые определяются пунктиром. Вот так.
Это означает, что человек эти его состояния, он их не использует.
То есть, Настюш, тогда, когда ты сейчас навела пример с мамой, у тебя было очень много
батьківського, дорослого,
але малюка, ти ж не можеш
в свои власні потреби в 15 років,
але ти маєш ці потреби мати,
задовольнити.
Але маму сесила, такая,
каже, ой, божечки, людочки,
шо ми будемо робити,
як ми будемо жити,
то вона не використовувала
своих двоего стана,
батьківського и дорослого.
Тому вони так и позначаются
в симбиозах пунктирами.
Тобто завжди есть какая-то людина,
которая может вас затягивать
до этого симбиоза.
Иногда это могут быть родители, иногда просто мы не можем выдержать какие-то проблемы.
Но симбиоз, он всегда ограничивает развитие нашей автономии.
И когда мы начинаем поступать в симбиоз с любой людьми, в первый раз люди себя чувствуют комфортно в этом симбиозе.
Людям, кстати, иногда нравится симбиоз. Им комфортно, им классно, им прикольно. Одна людина решает какие-то проблемы,
Инша людина радеет этому, да, и начебто все роли, они задоволены.
Но и каждый из участников этого симбиоза, он выполняет свою роль,
такую, какую от него ожидают.
Но этот комфорт, он достигается за определенную цену.
Люди, которые находятся в симбиозе, блокируют свои возможности
вообще решить эту проблему.
И с тем временем накопляются образы и раздражение.
То есть, с которым я должен решить твою проблему всю жизнь.
А другая людина ожидает, что ты будешь решать эту проблему всю жизнь.
И, смотрите, пастка симбиоза в том, что, первое, в нем комфортно, в этом симбиозе.
Второе. Каждый из участников оттеняет часть своего эго-стана или своих ресурсов.
И защита от выхода из симбиоза.
Человек говорит, что сам без этой человека не впораюсь.
Я сам не справлюсь.
И помните, мы тогда учили с вами игры.
Ну, в кого-то разные игры, да, так, але, там, шо ще, да, пни мене, то все игры, они развиваются с неразвязанного симбиоза, где люди не оценивают себя, або выправдывают, ну, эту игру своей грандиозностью, або, говорят, не имеют выхода.
Это понятно? Про симбиоз.
Человек не может решить самостоятельно свои проблемы,
и комфортно, она вас пригласила, вы сказали, что будете это делать.
Сейчас сделаем такую большую практику.
Пожалуйста, напомните свои отношения.
С будь кем, мне все равно, с кем напомните.
Но подумайте, есть ли у вас в этих отношениях симбиоз?
Теперь к вам очень классное вопрос.
Каким образом вы приглашаете партнера к этому симбиозу?
Кто из вас какую роль выполняет?
Кто что снеценил в себе?
И если вы измените свою поведенку, то какие возможны позитивные последствия выхода из этого симбиоза?
На все про все, 10 по 5 минут в каждую сторону.
Кого запрошу, как запрошу и что будет, если изменюсь?
Если долгое время ты автономна.
Хорошо.
Я сейчас пытаюсь родителей, детей, друзей, вообще от них не завишу.
Хорошо. Но они же как-то притягивают обратно вас в симбиоз, да?
То есть каким образом они притягивают?
Что они говорят вам, чтобы вы возвращали симбиоз?
Тебя же никто не выпустил.
Водители, допустим, через заботу.
Ну, это же неплохо.
Ну, если эта забота не подавляет никого, конечно, чудесно.
Хорошо.
Не подавляет.
Тогда у вас нет симбиоза, тогда у вас всё здорово.
Попадаю с высочек.
Пожалуйста.
звук влада инсайты зрения офигенный симбиоз самый офигенный симбиоз это в сексе за добрый
я рада, я рада, что
он есть, это действительно прикольно
а, хорошо, кроме секса
в кого еще какие
виды симбиоза есть?
я сейчас буду дальше рассказывать
про нездоровый симбиоз
Настя, давай, скажи
оно получается как пошло, да, вот
так оно и шло, шло, шло
и в принципе к тебе уже так
подключаются к симбиозу другие
другие люди, другие
пока ты, да, эту ситуацию
не скидываешь, ну и
жизни поставить так что ты уже все или ты умрешь или ты или не умрешь и тут уже вопрос жизни и
смерти скидывать ну да да это правда потому что в этом есть свои сложности если у нас долго этот
симбиоз помните до источник где бы он не был кстати они в сексе или не в сексе у другого
партнера будет раздражение если ты без конца в пассивная позиция в ожидании до наступит тот
момент и потому что часто мы говорим сейчас все таки про патологические формы симбиоза где другой
скажет а где моя доля до венгрина нет и ну и она держит двух сторон может быть и тех тот кто по
сну очень-очень грубо говоря пассивный до зависимы в этой истории и те кто решала этот тот получать
из-за того что обесценивается сам он тоже начинает раздражение получать по инвалидам
каким-то и и он тоже раздражение это получает и а этот естественно место еще какой-то там
благодарности тоже получает раздражение и сам раздражается шути по надо вот мы будем про это
сейчас говорить и мы будем говорить про тоже про интересные штучки такие да как конкурентный
симбиоз на чуть-чуть попозже то не а слуха владимир и питания вот еще наприклад людина
сведомо хочет быть в состоянии жертвы, в состоянии ребенка, то есть она это признает, она говорит, что я хочу
в этом быть. Какая будет лучшая поддержка для нее, для того, чтобы не идти в этот симбиоз и не
спасать, например? Это очень хорошее вопрос. Это все нужно знать. Даже в симбиоз можно зайти по контракту.
контракту, ну и с клиентом, и с близкими людьми, да,
то есть, человек говорит, хорошо, я сейчас не готова,
у меня нет ресурса решать это вопрос, так иногда
говорят клиенты, хорошо, хорошо, я тебя слышала, давай,
сколько времени тебе нужно, чтобы быть в этом процессе?
Три недели, супер, или там до 25 травня, потому что 25
звонок в травне, да, все будут свободны, дети будут
я буду делать все, что захочу. О, хорошо, тогда за контрактом все нормально.
Или задать такое вопрос. Тебе нужна моя помощь?
Я такое вопрос про поддержку задавала, но человек не знает, как можно поддержать.
И я не знаю. Я не знаю, какая нужна, например, ваши титанцы, матуси.
знаю какая поддержка, почему я должен прийти к другому человеку. Я говорю, хорошо, подумай, когда будет
ответ, дай мне знать, я рядом. Ага, так заходит? Супер, супер, хорошо, идем дальше. И вот сейчас мы начинаем
рассматривать все эти виды для здорового и нездорового симбиоза. Смотрите, если нормальный здоровый симбиоз,
он возник, потому что там ребенок взрослый, да, он дает возможность человеку дальше стать спонтанным,
осознанным и близким, потому что у него все потребности, они удовлетворены. Слушайте, еще есть пример здорового симбиоза,
например, кому-то делали когда-то операцию? Ну делали, да, мы же все взрослые люди, так бывает, там может стоматолог,
или еще что-то. Вот здоровый симбиоз
это когда тебе сделали что-то,
а ты там не действительный
сейчас, да, и рядом с тобой стоит
медсестра.
А это здоровый же симбиоз.
Ты сейчас не можешь выполнять какие-то
функции. Это нормальный здоровый
симбиоз. А потом, я не знаю, там впал,
не дай Боже, на колено.
У тебя болит колено.
Действительно, оно болит.
Вот это у меня моя подруга, она разбила себе
колено, ей очень плохо стало.
то ее поклали на кресло и повезла.
Здоровый симбиоз.
Здоровый.
То есть я не могу использовать один из своих или некоторых его станций
для того, чтобы себя обслуговывать.
И это я нормальным.
Но когда есть разные процессы,
есть в людей и нездоровые симбиозы.
И нездоровые симбиозы.
Потому что в здоровом симбиозе, как отличить здоровое от нездорового, что в здоровом каждый из сторон не игнорирует свои его состояния.
Она не игнорирует, она осознает, что сейчас эти его состояния, они недеиздатные.
Недеиздатные, понимаете, поэтому, когда там операция, что-то произошло, просто я сейчас недеиздатная, я не могу это сделать.
Або там дитина, когда она взрослая, то она не может это сделать.
И для того, чтобы не створить нездоровый симбиоз,
внимание, нам необходимо осознавать наши собственные потребности
нашей собственной внутренней дитине.
То есть, нездоровый симбиоз – это когда мы игноруем свои потребности.
То есть, либо кто-то что-то не делает, либо кто-то делать ничего не хочет.
Здоровый симбиоз – это когда мать и дитя до 1 года или до 3-х лет.
В взрослом возрасте кто болеет после операционного периода.
Или временный симбиоз за контрактом.
Какие-то экстремальные события, или человек очень утомился.
У нас нет такого, к сожалению, состояния, когда мы можем прийти к партнеру и сказать,
ну, сейчас может уже есть, прийти и сказать, я так утомился, давай сегодня я буду этой милой лялечкой.
сегодня кого нянчим, а меня нянчим, да, або партнер может прийти и сказать, это здорово, это нормальный симбиоз, да, вот я втомлена,
но как у нас происходит у родины, мы будем про это сейчас говорить, так, Василий, скажи.
Вот менторство, або тренерство, это тоже выглядит, как здоровый симбиоз за контрактом, когда человек хочет какой-то цели,
если кто-то проведет заручку, а не...
Да, если за контрактом, если она чего-то не знает,
если она просит, чтобы тебя научили, это также здоровый симбиоз,
в некотором состоянии, то есть, если ты сидишь и молчишь,
например, и не решаешь вместо этой людины проблемы,
то все нормально, все классно.
И мне относится триггерить слово симбиоз,
потому что с точки зрения биологии и симбиоза, это тогда, когда двое существуют, и обе двое добрые.
А когда один из архонок пришел, то с точки зрения биологии это было паразитство,
то есть у нас есть умовно патологичная микрофлора, которая нам не шкодит.
Вот это был симбиоз, что она живет в себе в нам, мы в себе живем с ней.
Вот, и поэтому у меня тут где-то момент, а бояться что-то с той биологией.
Ты что-то перечитал? Нет, ты просто по-другому на это смотришь. Знаешь, есть такие рыбки, в них есть вот этот слизь. Ну, слизь на рыбе есть. Ну, рыба плавает, она не защищает. А есть такие маленькие малюсочки, они прицепились к этих маленьких рыбочкам. Я вот это, когда купалась, видела. Великая рыба, а возле нее такие маленькие.
И они просто съедают эту патологическую флору. Это же здоровый симбиоз. И большие рыбы хорошо, и маленькие хорошо. Они как-то за контрактом взаимодействуют. Один к одному биологично подтягиваются.
Мать и дитя. Здоровый симбиоз, здоровый симбиоз. Хвороба, здоровый симбиоз, симбиоз здоровый. А патологический симбиоз, это когда эта рыба приперлась и съела всю микрофлору большой рыбы. А та померла.
То есть нам просто нужно понять, что здорово, а что нет.
И вот в транзакционном анализе нормальный здоровый симбиоз выглядит вот так.
У нас же все по схеме, знаете, ФТА, это основные схемы.
Здоровый симбиоз выглядит вот таким образом.
Смотрите, есть маленькая дитя, она приходит к своим родителям
И начинает активировать все три его станы родителей.
Або кто-то, не дай Боже, захворел.
Есть своя потребность.
И ты начинаешь активировать там мужа или дружину,
все три его станы, пожалуйста, попекайся про меня.
Вот так рисуется здоровый симбиоз.
Но нездоровый симбиоз, когда человек взрослый, но не может научиться пикловать про себя, относительно своего века.
И, чаще всего, прерывание здорового симбиоза, девчата, внимание, происходит из-за инициативы мамы.
То есть мама сама разрушает иногда здоровые отношения со своей детьми.
И потом дитя, оно вынуждено быть в этом симбиотическом состоянии.
То есть если мы подумаем, как это мама делает,
например, дитя, чтобы выжить, начинает проявлять любые пассивные стили поведения.
Она может плакать, когда она не задоволена.
Она может не включаться в игру.
Она может адаптироваться, стать занадто хорошей детьми.
Настя, кстати, ты про это говорила сегодня,
что вы должны были брать какие-то свои истории родственные.
Это называется нададаптация.
Эта штука, к которой тебя стимулировали твои родители, называется нададаптация.
Ты стала занадто хорошей дитиной, чтобы решить проблемы вместо других людей.
И есть игнорирование.
То есть, человек становится хорошей дитиной.
А может быть, когда ты, например...
Ну, извини, Настюш, ты сегодня про это уже так же сказала.
Не могла решить эти проблемы тут и сейчас.
Появляется вот это возбуждение.
Вот.
И вот так выглядит в транзакционном анализе симбиоз.
Смотрите, какая красивая схема.
Две людины, но каждый игнорирует свои какие-то процессы.
И они из шести его стандартных имеют только три.
Разом, на двух.
Катя, какие вопросы?
Спасибо. У меня вопрос, у меня сыну 4 года, и я вот думаю, в этом, казалось бы, можно на русском, до года, до 3 лет, вот в основном так.
И я сейчас понимаю, что у меня нездоровый симбиоз, потому что у меня сын только начинает строить глазки и говорит, я не могу, и я за него всё делаю.
Вот, там, например, я не могу сам одеться, и я его одеваю, я его кормлю.
То есть это уже я формирую нездоровый симбиоз,
и как-то что-то мы ещё с утра проходили, тоже я заметила.
Да, есть какие-то элементы нездорового симбиоза, Катя.
То есть, если, например, он говорит, я не могу,
я спрашиваю, а что ты можешь сам на себя одеть?
Он говорит, ну, он начинает тут как-то…
Если ты меня не оденешь, ты меня не любишь.
Нет, я тебя очень люблю, но одеваться тебе надо научиться самостоятельно.
Смотри, что ты можешь сам одеть?
Ну, например, я знаю, что дети в этом возрасте, они могут нормально одеть футболки.
Одень футболку. Хорошо, одел футболку, да.
А вот колготки, которые нам натягивали когда-то, или детям иногда надо натягивать, да, они не могут одеть.
Окей, хорошо, давай помогу. И буду помогать, пока ты не научишься, да.
То есть, в чём тебе нужна моя помощь?
Вообще, с детьми без конца надо задавать эти вопросы.
Как я тебе могу помочь? Что я тебе могу сделать? Что я могу для тебя сделать?
давай сделай это сам, если у тебя не получится,
я тебя научу. Особенно с
мальчиками. А если он говорит,
я ничего не могу, я ничего не хочу?
И я ничего не могу,
и я ничего, сына, сегодня не хочу.
Такое мама стоит. Я поняла, я просто
потом не выдерживаю вот этих там,
если он впадает в истерики.
И мне легче
быстрее его одеть, чем выдержать
состояние. Конечно, я
сама мама, да, попробуй собраться там,
тебе надо ехать в школу, да, и они
все ходят там, кто шнурки когда-то
завязывал, кто что-то там одевал,
кто куртку найти не может, кто рюкзак
дотянуть не может. Понятно,
ты как мама хочешь сорваться. И вот здесь
очень важно не приглашать детей
в нездоровый симбиоз, а дать им возможность
самим опоздать в школу,
не приехать
вовремя, пойти с нерасчёсанными
волосами. Делов-то.
Благодарю.
Пожалуйста.
И таким чином мы
сформовали оцененный здоровый симбиоз
за иншую людину.
И эти симбиозы, они ограничивают нашу автономию.
Мы не можем ни думать, ни выражать свои чувства, ни удовлетворить свои потребности.
И смотрите, есть очень классная мета симбиоза.
Мета симбиоза – это удовлетворить потребности, которые не были удовлетворены в детстве.
То есть, если в детстве какие-то ваши потребности не были удовлетворены,
вы всю жизнь будете искать человека, с которым вы сможете сформировать тот симбиоз, чтобы удовлетворить свои детские потребности.
То есть вы будете подсведомо игнорировать какие-то чувства.
Слушайте, давайте классику жанра расскажу.
Народилась дитина у родителей.
Она не может нормально функционировать.
Мама в ночи женится до этой дитыни, годовать ее.
Ну, было такое? Да?
Мама в этот час втомлюется, потому что она не спит ночами.
Мама свой детский состояние игнорует, потому что она же не спит.
Так что, чтобы мама не стала стервой, такая, которая кидается на дитину, на тата, на людей,
тата в этот час должен удовлетворить потребы мамы.
И запытаться, сонечко, моя родная, ты сегодня не выспалась, давай, может, я принесу ежу какую-то, а дитину погодую.
И тогда все будет хорошо в родине.
Но если даже есть здоровый симбиоз с дитиной, а кто-то в этом симбиозе, например, мама, не высыпается, не может найти себе час на отдых.
Вы знаете, сколько пар они вообще разлучаются в первый год рождения детей? Сколько конфликтов. Все было так романтично, все было так офигенно. Я всегда говорю, ваше жизнь, семейное, оно начинается только тогда, когда вы родили детей.
Все кризисы начинаются в этот момент. Все проявляется до этого. Секс, кекс, все классно, ремонтик, все офигенно. Грошей дофига. Народилась дитина, что происходит? А кто станет? А что делать? А чего ты это не делаешь?
Вот недавно у меня была такая интересная пара, она говорила, а я не хочу няню, я не хочу, чтобы какая-то людина моя чужая до моей дитыни шла, я не хочу. А ты можешь, гад, человек, прийти и в ночи встать и смотреть за этой дитинкой. Это же ты можешь быть хорошим татом.
Он говорит, слушай, любовь моего жизни, ты вообще не офигела в этом жизни? Я обеспечу тебя машиной, житлом, няню я тебе предлагаю, я не могу встать, мне на восьмую нужно уже быть на работе и работать, не работать без конца, алло, давай договоримся.
Он мне говорит, что я не тот папа, которого я ожидала увидеть в этой жизни.
Всё, разрушение. Разрушение, ты меня не понимаешь. Ты плохой папа.
Понимаете? И это реалии жизни. То нужно просто смотреть и формировать этот симбиоз здоровья по контракту.
То есть с каждым человеком, если у вас там... Василий, ты что-то хотел сказать, или у меня уже была галлюцинация?
Я хотел сказать, но, конечно, на сегодняшний день, думаю, поступите договориться. Правильно я слышал, что мы шокируем людей, таких, которые смогут задолбить потребы, которые мы не получили в детстве, да?
Тоже возникает мысль, что мы притягиваем людей по травмам, то есть, если у меня была мама холодная,
я притягиваю холодную женщину. Как тогда это? У меня есть террор, я, наоборот, должен притянуть
человека, с которым я доотримываю то, что я не взял, а я притягиваю человека, с которым я не доотримываю.
И что происходит, какая изменения происходят, когда, например,
нехай притягивает все-таки та женщина, которая полностью дает то, что нужно.
То есть идет исцеление, а тогда уже здоровейшие личные цели, или все, что есть.
Смотри, пока ты притягиваешь к себе холодных женщин,
у тебя есть потребность в теплом контакте,
и ты получаешь от этой холодной снежной женщины возбуждение,
то у тебя есть нездоровый патологический процесс.
То есть, ты снова и снова ищешь, как удовлетворить потребность, какую потребность невозможно удовлетворить холодной женщине.
Но когда ты уже проходишь психотерапию, тебя холодные женщины не сбудживают.
И ты начинаешь искать женщину, ну, потому что до этого ты ее недооценил, сказал, блин, я каос, и она какая-то такая, ну, как бы сказать, скучная что-то.
Что-то, блин, не такая драматичная.
не выносит мне ничего из головы, вообще что с ней делать, она какая-то не такая, нет, как будто ничего, такая фигура, но что-то такое не такое, вот понимаешь, вот как мне клиенты говорят, не вставляй, знаешь, вот нет ничего, вот не сбудешь, не встает, не встает, да, да, да, но она так и говорит, да, або женщины говорят, Боже, Боже, я не могу, я же только про него думаю, про кого ты думаешь,
А про того токсика, который на нее не смотрит, который с ней не общается, который не отвечает на сообщения, потому что она уже 159 сообщений написала, а там игнор.
Або дети, да, ты с ними общаешься, как интересно формуется вот эта детка уже, там, детине 14 лет, в подлете, ты ей спрашиваешь, слушай, а кого ты любишь? А я люблю вот того, с девятого, шестого класса. А ты сейчас в каком? В девятом.
То есть, ты 3 года любишь парня, который тебя игнорирует? Да, да.
А он тебя любит? Нет.
А что ты делаешь 3 года? Страждаешь.
Понимаете, да, какой процесс интересный?
Когда мы исцелены, то мы притягиваем позитивных людей.
Когда мы не исцелены, не протерапевтованы, мы притягиваем тот самый сильный опыт,
для того, чтобы наконец-то исцелиться.
Да, да. Люди, знаете, я хочу поделиться с вами опытом. У меня есть проблема. Знаете, какая?
Я не могу смотреть эти сериалы или эти драматические фильмы, да, там типа «Невымовные грехи» или еще что-то. Я смотрю и думаю, боже, какие блин.
Вот мне не интересно смотреть, не заходит оно как-то, я не могу смотреть нормальное кино, это сложница была, да, кино там такое, рейтинги, блин, офигенные.
Я пошла, посмотрела, думаю, боже, боже, где вы один одного нашли? Короче, когда ты уже проходишь психотерапию, тебе это все, это все сумно, то есть оно тебя как-то не драйвит.
Ты видишь рейтинг, РНБ, что там есть космическое, а ты сидишь и думаешь, боже, когда оно уже заканчивается.
Кажу, пошли с этого, я не могу это смотреть. А у меня проблема. У меня, люди, есть большая проблема.
Не могу смотреть кино. Катя, скажи.
Вы говорили про родину, да? У меня так же полностью один в один складывалась ситуация.
Единственное, что я не сказала, что мужчина плохой отец, не переходила на личное.
Как женщинам, очень много женщин с этим встречаются.
Как с этим быть?
Как находиться с этим?
У меня есть плохая новость, Катя.
Плохая новость.
Он никогда не изменится.
Что ты будешь делать, если твой мужчина никогда не изменится?
Вот я понимаю, он никогда не будет там, ну, предположим, ну, подружилась, вышла замуж, он всегда был тем человеком, который мог закрыть, я не знаю, что там, например, это я себе сейчас фантазирую, проживание, машину купить.
А вот до детей он не был таким.
Ну что делать?
Он не изменится.
Хорошо, что ты будешь делать, если человек не изменится?
Ты что, будешь гонять за ним на метле,
сказать, я тебе говорю, я тебе наказываю,
я тебя зачеклую.
Никогда не изменится человек.
Ничего. А что делать с своим состоянием?
Я вспоминаю, что у меня была послеродовая депрессия
в тот период, когда я осталась одна с этим.
И дальше я уже понимаю, что если я буду планировать другую ребенка, какой бы человек ни был, то я должен понимать, что в меня должна быть няня, чтобы не упасть из родины.
Да. То есть, если ты не игнорируешь свой состояние взрослого, то ты уже понимаешь, что человек не встанет в ночь кормить ребенка. Но не научили его так родители. Ну что, это плохо? Такое жизнь, так бывает. То как можно попеклеваться про себя, чтобы мы не убили один с одним с мужем, пока там ребенку будет один год. Нанять ничную няню.
А если у женщин нет денег? Вот они уже сейчас в таком состоянии.
Говорят, нужно подумать, как это сделать. Нужно взять своего любимого и сказать, что мы будем делать. Я утомилась, у меня нет денег. Нет, Василий, так мы не делаем. Это негуманно. Мы взрослые люди. Нас не можно, Василий, не показывать.
Нужно не одной рукой, а двумя, да, типа сразу?
Нет, Василий, мы не такие люди.
Мы нормальные, мы дорожные люди.
Мы должны запропоновать своему мужу или другому,
какой есть выход из этой ситуации.
И посидеть, Катя, и подумать, может, человек какой-то выход принесет.
Сказать, любимый, знаешь, у меня есть большая проблема.
Какая? У меня после пологовой депрессии.
Что мне делать?
Как мне быть?
У нас еще такие дурные женщины, извините, девочки, я не хочу никого обижать, но мы как в той рекламе, завжди куда-то бежим, а сейчас мы будем это изучать.
Называется конкурентный симбиоз. Не делайте ничего. Женщины, не делайте ничего. Домашнее задание, не делать ничего.
По ту сторону экрана, типа, ты своей маме спитайся, какая у нее была после родовой депрессии.
Она тебя выховала, и еще трех таких, как ты выховала.
И твоему бате ничего не говорила.
А Юра, это уже знецинение моих почутей.
Это не гуманность, Юра.
Так не можно разговаривать со своей женой.
Надо сказать, да, любимый, я тебя понимаю.
Сейчас решим это вопрос.
И ты реши.
Не можно так сказать.
Мы не можем знецинить.
у человека есть свои чувства, Юра, не может так.
Нет, это да, я просто говорю про большинство диалогов,
потому что я не раз слышу, я к нему приезжаю,
а он мне такое выдает, я говорю, он так, блядь.
Ну, слушайте, это нормально, это жизнь, все будут не оценивать,
да, потому что люди не хотят решать проблемы.
Сейчас идем дальше к этому симбиозу, очень красиво, да.
То есть, вспомните какие-то свои там отношения, да,
как вы это формуете свои нездоровые симбиозы.
Згадайте это все.
И думайте про то,
как вы самостоятельно втягиваете
другую людину к этому симбиозу.
То есть нормально, когда мы дети,
мы в симбиозе, потом он исчезает,
и когда людина становится взрослой,
она сама живет за своим желанием.
Но в течение наших отношений
мы всегда проигрываем эти паттерны поведения.
Пожалуйста, сделайте свою работу.
Сейчас вспомните, пожалуйста, свои незадоволенные потребности в детстве.
Незадоволенные потребности.
Что вы хотели получить, а так не получили.
И подумайте, как вы эти незадоволенные потребности,
как ты, Василий, мне сегодня уже рассказал секрет
про притягивание холодных женщин,
выиграете сейчас в своем жизни.
То есть каким образом вы...
Я не про тебя сейчас, я про всех. Вы притягиваете эти нездоровые отношения, симбиотические связки, как вы их формуете.
Хорошо? Давайте поговорим о моих потребностях, что я хочу отрабатывать и почему я это не отрабатываю.
Может, с этого времени вы будете по-другому ставиться к отношениям.
На все про все 10 минут.
А вот картинка, да, вот, если проигрывать, холодная мама, холодная дружина, и не сбудживали, типа, теплые девчата, да, и когда, сейчас, умовно говоря, пошел в отношения не так за сбуджением, а вот где-то просто они доигрались, наигрались.
И как раз в этих отношениях есть много тепла, дозорности, поддержки.
То есть, за нормальные условия я бы от них отказался,
потому что у меня там не было этого кодика, о котором ты говоришь.
За ненормальные условия ты бы отказался.
Ты неправильно формулируешь думку.
За нормальные условия у меня в прошлом?
За ненормальные условия.
То есть, то, что было раньше, это патологический процесс.
Это нездорово, Василий. Нормальные отношения, они должны быть, смотри, Василий, когда мы одинаково...
Я не понимаю, я понял. Как бы потяг. То есть для меня нормальные условия, это явный потяг.
И для меня вступать в отношения без явного сильного потягу, это ненормально. Вот про что я.
Смотри, потяг появится с часу, потому что все, что необычное, оно в начале лякает.
Вот ты видишь другого человека и думаешь, блин, какой капец, я бы никогда с ним не был.
То есть это эксперимент, один из крутых способов создать новый опыт, в который бы я просто по стандартному не пошел.
что я где-то в разы стал зрелее, лучше, вкуснее и, но что меня удивляет, здоровее, да, что меня
удивляет, что притянулася человек кардинально противоположный по осознанности, по психотерапии,
то есть она на нулевом этапе, она там два раза психолога была, грубо говоря, и там духовность
практически вообще ничего не резает, а я где-то здесь, по крайней мере, в другом, и она меня так
Я не думал, что люди настолько относительно разных взглядов могут притянуться.
И тут для меня вызов есть опуститься и не качать то, что я иногда делал в отношениях.
И прямо принять эту такую иначесть.
Это для меня прямо открытие.
Я почувствовал даже чувство правды, что я в этих отношениях.
Аля не до конца правдивый, бла-бла-бла.
Я пошел четко за опытом, и этой человеке я тоже говорю, я сейчас не играю в супер что-то там, я играю за опыт.
Но ее травмы такие же самые, она тоже недоторканная, недолюбленная, немного холодная.
Но в принципе она готова это давать, и это прям вау-эффект.
То есть и мы один к одному, в принципе, одинаковые мовы любви.
Поэтому вот мне прям было интересно это почувствовать от тебя.
Доброе, это же классно. Знаешь, Василий, я всегда рада, когда люди перерабатываются.
И это действительно очень важно, перенавчиться, понять, что я здоров, что я нездоров.
Потому что то, что научили родители, это патологический процесс, он нездоровый.
А люди воспринимают, как будто так оно должно быть.
То есть, как ты говоришь, нормальный я, за моим нормальным опытом.
И ты сам подсознательно ищешь, как ее оценивать, сказать, у меня такой опыт психотерапии, у нее такой опыт.
Я себя оцениваю, наверно.
Во-первых, я себя оцениваю, а потом уже и ее.
И ты и себя, и ее, всех оцениваешь, знаешь, и вот таким образом, ну, немного отдаляешься, да, от человека, и ты попробуй, иди и попробуй, иди уже и попробуй, и ты попробуй, как тебе, один раз, два раза, три раза, да, то есть через некоторое время оно изменится по-другому.
Кажется, сегодня прям революционный день, и вот эти все вещи, это для меня большая благодарность,
потому что с утра, типа, что мужчины делают пассивность через подростковую маму,
и у меня есть это, я очень много, не так пассивность, как я делаю много, но не только по цели, что у меня самое важное.
И прямо вот этот запрос к терапевту, сейчас дальше, правда, не знаю, какую историю найти, знаешь, прямо вот это, что мужчина...
Ничего такого нет, просто это всегда происходит, потому что мама не поддерживала, она не сказала, блин, ты такой офигенный, блин, ты такой молодец, так, ну может не такая яичная, но все, хлебушек, бекон, салатик, все красиво.
знаешь, а вот эти матуси,
которые, ну, такие задуманные
и прискипливые до себя,
они еще и больше прискипливые
до своих сыновей.
Не умеют мамы
любить безумовно, на жаль.
Ну, видишь, в принципе, то, что ты говорила, погладживание,
я иногда говорю, что я не в комбинации, и, в принципе,
это меня и вытянуло. Роков
два, когда я начал это вести, и, в принципе, да.
Ах, киндент, да.
Спасибо, не буду тебя угрожать, а потом приедем.
Ну, потому что мне интересно было именно вот это зайти, типа, чем это было.
Так или иначе твой взгляд прям, вот у меня это прям было вопросом уважения к проекту.
Нового опыта, и это некомфортно.
И правда, создал на дистанции, но не дай, что на дистанции.
Типа, это всё равно побезопаснее, чем каждый раз, скажем так.
я на старой ласку и китовша чахал скажу тебе 2 холинки
И спрашиваю тебя дальше, а после нашего МСММ, неужели можно пойти к тебе на другой курс сразу на
второй год? Первый год вы прошли, но вы его более тесно прошли, но все равно есть понимание, знаешь, того,
что там есть основным. Да, оно есть, да, потому что у вас есть понимание, я очень много вам даю. Просто, когда у меня
семинар, там очень много практики, и люди 12 часов сидят и изучают одну тему, а у нас тут, ну, что у нас тут?
Восемь, наверное. Да, ну меньше, чем восемь. Да, восемь, да, потому что сорок минут нас на перерыве все. Да, восемь часов, то есть и одна треть.
Потому что я чаще всего иду в вересне в институт, у меня есть неврология, и я там за четыре месяца возьму психотерапевта, да, эту специализацию.
Но я всё равно хотел бы потом иметь высокий напрямок, то есть мне психотерапия занудна, но в комплексе с коучингом, с менторством, со всеми, оно даёт классные результаты, как на меня.
Если ты дальше будешь остаться в Украине и работать в Украине, там уже будут принимать до 30-го года закон про психотерапию, про коучинг и про менторство.
И то, что должно быть у людей, которые в Украине, у них должно быть узкоспециализированное диплом.
Будь какой там, там есть, нужно закон посмотреть, Василий, это очень важно.
То есть, за какими направлениями ты можешь работать в этой специальности.
Або девчонкам задать там вопросы.
Вот относительно психотерапевтов я точно знаю, а относительно коучев я не очень знаю, каким должен быть диплом.
Ну, потому что я уже имею диплом психолога, то мне уже легче.
Да, я встал еще за полтора года, потому что сейчас все психологи уже имеют только за 4 года, без бакалавра психологии уже нельзя.
Это важно, да, там должны быть много баллов.
Ну, да, как лекарства.
Да, как лекарства, лицензия. Юля, слушаю.
Я хотела поделиться, потому что я хотела на эту работу быть слушателем,
ну, там, какие-то вопросы решить свои.
Но так получилось, что не было с кем попрацовать, и я працевала.
И на самом деле, насколько классно быть включенной в эту работу.
Потому что, ну, когда вы просто проговорили эту работу, я такая, ну, окей.
А когда мы с Снежаной только что говорили, вот я прям хочу ей поблагодарить,
сколько осознанности появляется, когда ты проговоришь это.
Поэтому очень-очень классно.
Здоровья. Я люблю, когда вы включены.
Знаете, иногда такой облом бывает
работать, но я вас прошу,
пожалуйста, говорите один с одним.
У вас такая офигенная комьюнити.
У вас так классно. У вас хорошая группа.
У вас очень похожие
стили поведения, ценности.
Вы мне неимоверно подобаетесь.
Вы такие лидеры.
Вы очень хорошие, очень такие
мощные, офигенные люди.
И энергия у вас есть.
И вот эта
способность жить есть.
И вы такие интересные, и вопросы.
То есть, вы знаете, каждая группа, она по-разному выглядит.
Это как дети.
Ну, мы лучше, да, чем вторая?
Так, стоп, вы не лучше.
Я когда-то остался и слушал, как Влада...
Мы первые.
Нет, нет, Влада говорила, была с помощником.
И Влада сказала, что в другой части он теоретичнейший,
а мы такие практичнейшие.
Вот это когда-то от Влады так слышал.
Вы совсем разные.
Вы совсем разные, вы такие в меня, да, такие заинтересованные, такие, знаете, в комьюнити, я вижу, да, такие очень, а там же такие другие вопросы, вообще, совсем разные.
Вы как дети, и я люблю у вас этот потек, потому что это мой первый тут потек, я его обожаю, да, я всегда там чекаю, мне так интересно, они совсем разные, вы разные.
И как можно сказать, что ты что, любишь правую сторону солнца больше, чем левую?
вырез не я вас люблю даже сильно настюшка же хорошее объяснение старшим детям о том что они
тоже любимые не только младший просто младшим нужно немножко больше внимания мы просто первые
дети я все знаю да есть иерархия всегда детей и потока первые они навсегда остаются первыми
И у меня старше ребенка, я говорю, ты меня дольше знаешь, чем эта маленькая, которая на минус 11 лет меньше.
Говорит, у тебя и у меня с тобой есть опыт на 11 лет больше.
То есть у нас с вами есть очень чудовитый, очень крутой опыт на целый год больше.
И вы меня знаете на целый год больше, и вы меня видели на целый год больше.
да тут это же крутой досвет и я вас такими знаю я тоже старше дочери что я ее я ее люблю на 14 лет
дольше и поэтому нужно младшим кому догнать из того было равенство это уже будет по-другому как
ни крути да то есть там уже будут другие взаимоотношения ну что как вы со своим
симбиозом разбираетесь давайте дальше есть какие-то вопросы за вопрос получается что
чтобы выстроить даже здоровый биос нужно четко понимать свои себя и свои свои по внутренней
потребности да потому что там удовлетворить мою там обида ребенка я упала то за ним все
равно что-то стоит там не уделили внимание да у нее то есть вот и тут чем лучше знаешь себя
к тому же смысл жизни то в принципе есть не познавать смысл жизни опознавать себя да да
очень мудрая ность слова и они абсолютно правдивы да вся наша жизнь это самопознание себя и через
это мы учимся любить других доброе и дома далее девица и надея люди ваны выбирают симбиоз видос
относительно того, как до них ставились родители. Я уже вам об этом говорила.
Есть разные жизненные позиции, из которых люди выбирают эти симбиозы.
Смотрите, первая симбиотическая позиция. Дети думают, что их образование настолько плохое,
что лучше я сам стану родителем. И тогда формуется этот родительский симбиоз,
где человек тянет на себя все. Да, понимаете? То есть не очень классные были родители.
И тогда дитя берет ответственность за чувство своих родителей.
То есть взрослые родители, они становятся детьми с такой людьми.
И вы можете подумать с этой жизненной позиции,
к которой вы заходите в этот симбиоз.
Возможно, вы думаете, что я окей, а они не окей.
Потому что так чаще всего входят в этот симбиоз.
эту симбиотическую позицию. Из этого он и формуется, из этого он и происходит. И мы приглашаем
людей к симбиозу. Как мы это делаем? Знаете, если бы мы были здоровыми нормальными людьми, нас кто-то
научил, мы должны прямо говорить о своих потребностях, как я вас сегодня учила. Но я приведу такой пример.
Представьте себе такую группу, ну группу знаете, может кто-то из вас проходил там групповую терпи, была у вас когда-то там, нет, не видели, ну представьте себе группу, вот представьте себе, мы с вами собираемся на такую живую группу, и вот заходит кто-то и начинает манипулировать нами,
То есть представьте себе, что заходит какая-то девочка, ну я не знаю, там Оленка, например, так ее назовем, с несчастным выглядом и говорит «мне нужно, чтобы кто-то меня обнял».
И она формует симбиоз, не симбиотичный поведение, когда она подходит, например, к Снежане и говорит «Снежан, я хочу, чтобы ты меня обнял».
То есть конкретно высказывает свои чувства. И когда вы начинаете работать с клиентами, если кто-то сидит и вещает в эфир, я хочу, чтобы кто-то что-то сделал. Было у вас такое когда-то?
Или мужчины, или женщины. Как вот сидят, например, мужчины говорят, что-то мне здесь жарко, или что-то мне еда не нравится, что-то сегодня там что-то пересохло. Что человек делает?
Людина, вместо нормального общения, она приглашает вас в симбиоз, чтобы вы как дурный или дурная подорвались, начали открывать окна, начали готовить еду, начали думать, что проблема у вас, начали не спать, начали не есть, начали дальше, ну, чувствовать себя не очень окейно.
И вот представьте себе, что в наших отношениях есть разные формы симбиоза.
Есть такая классная штука, называется «змогальный симбиоз».
Змогальный, конкурентный симбиоз, змогальный.
Мы змогаем, мы змогаем.
Сейчас будете шокировать, что там есть в ваших родинах.
Смотрите, змогальный симбиоз – это когда двое людей,
то есть вы и еще кто-то, прагнут взять на себя одну и ту самую симбиотичную роль.
И конкурируют за этот один эго-стан.
Двое людей прагнут взять на себя одну и ту самую роль.
Так, сейчас вспоминаю очень интересный случай.
Вспомните, когда вы были с кем-то в ресторане.
И вспомните, пожалуйста, когда приносят счет.
И вспомните, может быть, это еще до мужчин. Кто сегодня платит? Я плачу, не я плачу, я плачу, не я плачу. И как люди начинают конкурировать за тех, кто сегодня заплатит. Ну, было такое? Або, что, Снеженко, скажи?
Если кто-то, это мой чак человек всегда делает, кто-то делает вид, что пошел в туалет, и подрос из туалета, уже оплатил все счеты, потом, смотри на все эти пивничьи бои, а потом, на что же ты оплатил, да требовала я, да требовала я за все, это что означает?
А это означает, что он, как будто, или кто-то, какая-то людина, которая пошла, он боролся за этот родственный состояние, кто всего не платил.
То есть, он сразу всех убил, пока они боролись, он все и сделал.
Да, он пошел. А можно пойти, Снежана, скажи, пожалуйста, может, там когда-нибудь твой муж еще кого-нибудь в нашу группу запросит? Мы пойдем все с ним вместе.
Приезжайте на Кипр, приезжайте с радостью.
Прийти, есть, а потом мы будем ждать, будем разумными, ждать, пока он пойдет в туалет.
Но смотри, Лада, сын растет, да, и хотя он там еще, особенно там сам не зарабатывает, но подработает, и когда есть такой случай, что, например, семья идет, например, я, например, с Максом могу пойти куда-то, там, или поснился, или что, он так же делает, я уже, когда прошу счет, говорю, сыночку, ну что же, будем просить счет, он не требует уже оплаты, то есть он так же это делает.
Получается, что ему уже муж навязал этот стиль поведения?
Не навязал, показал, запропоновал.
Это здорово или не здорово?
По-моему, это неплохо.
Если сын не страждает, или муж не страждает,
Ну, хорошо, но когда человек уже страдает, знаешь, когда Снежана, он оплатил один счет, это хорошо, а когда 121, то он уже, может быть, нездоровый процесс, понимаешь, в чем есть проблема.
В основном, в большинстве он оплачивает, да, он оплачивает в основном в большинстве.
То есть, тут есть большое соперничество за родственную историю.
Доброе, понимаете, это очень важно.
Або другой такой детский вид симбиоза, как я говорю, кто сегодня будет лялечкой.
Ой, у меня депрессия.
Ну, нещедавно там слышала, да?
Або это как это происходит в дружеских отношениях.
Сейчас я сейчас вспоминаю, как это происходит.
Ой, Боже, я такой втомленный, я такой втомленный.
столько работы, столько работы, столько работы, мне столько всего нужно сделать, а оно что не втомлено?
То есть вот это испытание, конкурентный симбиоз, кто сегодня будет вот этим мальчиком?
И начинается, если ты не удовлетворяешь потребности этой женщины быть мальчиком, что начинается следующим?
А знаете, пара есть такая конкурентная, кто больше перехвореет? У него депрессия и у нее депрессия.
Он говорит, у меня депрессия 5 лет. Она говорит, и у меня 5 лет. И они конкурируют, кто сегодня будет этим кициком, манициком, таким маленьким мальчиком, которого будем сегодня нянчить.
смешно, но у меня недавно чуть не помыла сестра реально там три четыре операции пережила реально
она помирала только она богу дякувать из того вышла все жива-здорова ну таки психологически
там еще так вы можете хрома и я как проходит тиждень на иди человека открывается гиляка
разбивает ему голову, и теперь в него там зашиты, это все, это то, что будет где-то про то, что он
где-то не выдержал, и они подмогались за эту штуку, неизвестно даже, да? Да, да, неизвестно, что он
втомился. Втомился очень, я верю, да. Снежанка, Снежанка, слушай, плати иногда счетчики.
Нет, нет, это не про меня, это про соседнюю чушь. Я вообще тебе говорю. А, чтобы я, а я плачу, я плачу.
ну да вот не для примера интересно почему тогда я ну вот я например озвучиваю как здорово да я
не могу не вывожу устала не выгребаю чуть-чуть хочу скинуть кто возьмет а ты видел что в стране
творится от нервов не хватает она не так и бы мы не вывозим кто короче все начинают отбутывать не
моё типа типа никто не берет на себя и ну в этой ситуации я сдаюсь все ну падают дети все когда
передо мной падает ребенок вот это вот солдат ребенка не обидит все я встают поняла здесь
ребенок опять не я ну типа все тогда здесь я взрослый я принимаю всегда сдаюсь в это перед
детьми перед критикующими родителями могу попадаться перед детьми нет где тут оставить
здоровый симбиоз я ворую силу у другого человека настя так а ну ну типа но никто не хочет делать
все твой мячик лежит на поле или ты играешься сам или ты типа и я не буду делать то есть а
а настенька новая функция которую надо тренировать есть терпение и долготерпение у меня есть долго
терпения но у тебя его еще пока нет этот разум пора но ями долготерпение на другую сторону и
могу долго играть нездоровый симбиоз а ты не делай так больше есть терпение есть долготерпение ничего
не делать да потому что иначе другой человек никогда не вырастет если он без конца говорит
денег нет но вы держитесь денег нет но вы держитесь а вы закрываете все процессы без
конца то у него никогда этих денег и не будет а когда ему говоришь в ответ денег нет и в
принципе держаться не за что есть нечего пить нечего отдыхать нигде но тогда человек идет
работает так всегда бывает но тут что подключаться ты не можешь навязывать но ты же не можешь заставить
ручек а ты не можешь его потребовать ну-ну попросить по 3 не хотели я не могу но делать
за другого я не буду это не моя ответственность делать что-то за другого человека и не моя
ответы да и если кто-то ко мне приходит и начинают со мной конкурировать я говорю хватит играть со
мной в конкурирующий симбиоз хватит предлагать мне роль кто сегодня у нас будет куколкой
переучились
переучилась да это моя любимая фраза да про конкурирующий симбиоз может она очень часто
возникает у нас в отношениях.
Она прям нереальна.
Мы часто можем приглашать других людей
с нами в конкурирующий симбиоз
либо с точки зрения родителей,
либо с точки зрения ребёнка.
Надо осознать это всё,
это надо изменить.
Иначе, если мы не будем это менять,
тогда у нас будет большая проблема.
Слушайте, есть такая штука,
называется симбиоз второго порядка.
Давайте я вам, наверное, покажу, значит, смотрите, как выглядят вначале еще вот схемочки про симбиоз второго порядка позже, давайте вот это покажу.
Дивиться, оцей батьківський симбиоз, тобто змагання вирішує, хто буде головним, да, оці два його стане, оце, що Сніжана, ти сьогодні казала, воно отак виглядає, тобто інша людина, вона знає, я за тебе краще знаю, шо треба зробити, хто з нас буде головный, оце батьківський симбиоз, да, він так виглядає.
За что вообще люди конкуруют?
Почему они включаются в этот родственный симбиоз,
там, где именно про родственное его станет?
Это за власть, за решение, за деньги и за тех, кто прав.
Вот эта родственная штука.
И они не ценят, ну, знаете, иногда же кто-то хочет там показать себя,
они снеценивают другую женщину, что она тоже может это сделать.
И это вторая штука, да, вот это все.
Это соревнования за этот детский симбиоз.
В отношениях, кто крутейший, кто будет этой лялечкой.
Я болею, мне хуже.
И как только один высловляет любую нужду, другая людина начинает говорить, что мне это нужно также.
То есть это наибольший меч, когда у нас одинаковые нужды и когда люди начинают конкурировать за эту детскую позицию.
Доверенность.
А независимость? Когда ты больше за свою независимость?
За независимость принятия решений, за независимость, чтобы не навязывали, типа, чтобы свое еще.
Это не симбиоз, это называется отстаивание границ.
Ну, такая независимость настолько готова, что готова даже нести ответственность за другого, только чтобы принимать свои собственные решения.
Нет, это тогда за лидерство, это тогда включение в симбиоз.
да то есть например то что больше по это про включение то есть если ты берешь ответственность
за другого без спроса то это симбиоз не мне без спроса тебя просят ну что ты принимаешь
туда решение на тогда принимаешь решение несешь ответственность за двоих вот так почему я должна
принимать решение за двоих вот настолько настолько бьют не за это манипуляции зависимость даром и
гуляться я не буду принимать решение за двоих потому что мы две разные личности и я не буду
принимать решение 1 спасибо большое очень сета решать за двоих я не буду не надо меня приглашать
симбиоз, где я снова несу ответственность
за всю семью.
Понятно?
Да. Все, супер.
Идемте, идем и зараз
пообедаем, ах ты наев, да.
Завстречаемся в 10 хвилин.
Смачного всем.
Повернемся назад.
Скажите мне, пожалуйста, тут есть какие-то
вопросы? Или все понятно?
Нормально?
Что понятно, что не понятно?
Давайте
такую небольшую
работу сделаем.
А, еще, третий вид симбиоза,
очень интересный.
Есть такая штука, симбиоз второго порядка.
Возможно, где-то в вашем жизни
были такие отношения,
или родители так, да,
общались один с одним.
Один, например, обеспечивал
деньгами
родину,
а другой эмоционально
обслуговывал
другую людину.
Ну, знаете, так часто я иногда бываю
в психотерапии, да, и это называется симбиозом
другого порядка.
Сейчас я вам его покажу и про это расскажу.
Когда формуется, например, когда одна людина
пиклуется про другую людину на социальном уровне,
А другая людина пиклуется про другую людину на психологическом уровне.
Иногда так было в родственных отношениях с вами, возможно.
Родители вас обеспечивали социально.
А вы имели за это, например, услышать маму.
Мама имела жалеться на тата.
Понимаете? Таким образом в отношениях формуется симбиоз второго порядка.
То есть, когда есть с одной стороны обеспечение на социальном уровне
и на психологическом уровне, другая людина обслуживает другую людину.
Вот так это выглядит.
Сейчас покажу.
То есть есть обслуживание и на социальном, и на психологическом уровне.
Может, у вас когда-то были такие отношения с кем-то?
Или не было?
Хорошо, давайте сейчас сделаем вправо, невеликое вправо.
Вы разобьетесь на пару и подумайте, в отношениях каким образом вы включаете симбиоз.
Вы конкуруете за родственную позицию? Вы конкуруете за детскую позицию?
Вы обслуживаете какую-то людину, она вас на социальном уровне удовлетворяет ваши потребности, а вы удовлетворяете ее потребности на психологическом уровне?
Сколько тут слушателей?
Да, у нас уже не выходит, что у нас будет что-то.
Нет, тогда отмена.
Тогда я не буду с вами делать ничего.
Эту работу делать не буду.
Идем тогда дальше.
Смотрите, давайте переходим к тому, что есть клиенты,
которые будут приглашать вас в симбиоз.
И они при этом будут потребовать вас, и это нормально в отношениях.
Например, человек приходит к вам, и у него произошла какая-то страшная ситуация.
И она просит вас обращаться к ней.
Например, слушать ее, поддерживать ее, найти какие-то слова, которые ее поддерживают.
Как вы думаете, это нормально, это здоровый симбиоз?
Так?
Вас кто-то так просил делать работу?
Прямо нет.
Хорошо. Но даже на психологическом уровне вы можете понять, что у другой человека есть какая-то проблема, и ее нужно поддерживать. И ее нужно поддерживать в этом состоянии.
Что мы будем делать, если человек просто не приглашается, но предлагает нам симбиоз нездоровый в нашей работе?
Как нам работать с пассивным поведением? Хочете узнать?
Например, там какие-то отношения, а вам нужно как-то конфронтироваться с вашим клиентом.
Например, если человек говорит «Я не знаю, какие интервенции мы ей можем дать», вы можете ему сказать «Подумай, какие возможные будут решения? Что ты можешь сделать? Что ты делал до этого? Как ты решил эти проблемы до этого?»
Далее, вы можете надать информацию клиенту про то, что он это делал в прошлом.
Например, ты всегда это делал для своих родителей.
Поэтому сейчас ты делаешь это именно для своих, я не знаю, там, коллег, для своего окружения, в своей семье.
Або можете ему сказать, что ты делаешь это не потому, что ты это хочешь делать, а потому что хотят, чтобы ты это сделал другие.
Або можешь сказать другим людям, что ты можешь делать что-то для себя, а не для других.
И нам нужно людям доводить, что симбиоз – это нездорово, и что ты сам должен нести ответственность за то, что происходит с тобой.
Какие у нас есть конфронтации до каждого из этих типов, о которых мы сегодня говорили?
Ничего не делайте, смотрите, сделайте себе скрин просто слайдов.
Например, если есть пассивность, люди тихо говорят. Мы можем попросить их, говори четче, говори голоснее, переформулируй то, что ты хотел сказать.
Какой ты хочешь от меня контракт? Как я могу тебя поддержать? То есть, когда человек ничего не делает, вы сидите и ждете, что он может сделать по-другому.
Далее, при нададаптации,
людина адаптуется,
и нам нужно ей сказать,
ты можешь решить не проблемы других людей,
а ты можешь решить свои собственные проблемы
и удовлетворить свои собственные потребности.
Над ажитацией.
Нам нужно запитать человека, почему она так делает.
Почему она, что с ней происходит за несколько минут до того, как она начинает.
Або хотеть, або грызть ногти, або бить ручкой.
И тогда мы находим внутренний диалог этой людины, и мы его можем изменить.
Например, когда людина бегает, нервуется, мы можем ее спросить, ты сейчас нервуешь?
Что тебе нужно сделать, чтобы прекратить это возбуждение?
Або человек, когда что-то делает, нужно ей, ну, такая наджитованная, ей сказать, сядь и подумай хвилинку, что с тобой сейчас происходит, что ты сейчас чувствуешь, и что бы ты хотел отрабатывать, и удовлетворить ее потребность.
Далее. Бессилие или беспорядок.
Не давать много позитивных или негативных погладживаний, которые подсиляют эту поведенку.
И, например, отмывание в поддержке и турботе, когда человек так себя поводит.
Например, я понимаю, что ты себя так чувствуешь, я понимаю, что ты сейчас гниваешься, однако ты сюда пришел не для того, чтобы гниваться, а чтобы изменить свое жизнь.
Давай подумаем, что мы будем делать, если другая людина совсем не изменится.
Беспорадность. Я не знаю, а кто знает.
То есть вернемся к ответственности.
Вот такие у нас есть приемы.
Какая людина может использовать?
Все ли здесь понятно?
Да?
Все ли более-менее понятно, что делать, что не делать?
Хорошо.
Сейчас мы будем с вами приходить, подходить к матрице снисценивания.
А через грандиозность, как вот этот механизм защитного оценивания.
Сейчас я вам дам через некоторое время схему, с которой можно работать с клиентами.
Грандиозность – это то, что мы переборщиваем.
Я уже про это говорила.
Далее.
И оценивание – это когда человек не видит проблемы.
И сейчас мы начнем с вами рассматривать недостатки.
Пожалуйста, возьмите свои руки и сейчас нужно занотовать,
как человек может недостатковать проблему.
Ну что вообще, как происходит это недостаток.
Когда происходит какая-то проблемная ситуация. Например, я могу игнорировать себя, я могу игнорировать других или ситуацию.
Приклад. Официант разлив воду на меня.
Игнорование себя, когда я не звертаю внимание на то, что разлито вода.
Игнорование других, когда я критикую официанта, используя нецензурные слова.
Игнорирование ситуации, когда я говорю, что всех хорошо обслуживают, кроме меня, несправедливый этот мир.
Подумайте, когда у вас есть какая-то проблема.
Что вы игноруете?
Себе не обратите внимание, других критикуйте,
или игнорирование ситуации, вы говорите, что мир в этом виноват.
Разбейтесь, пожалуйста, на пары и на 10 минут поговорите, когда есть какая-то ситуация, что вы
игнорируете себя, критикуете других, или говорите, что это все мир в этом виноват.
если такого ну особо нет что нет никакой ситуации нет есть но обычно это обычно беру на себя
если так взять ну то ты говоришь я игнорирую себя да то есть моя привычка игнорировать и приписывать
проблему себе это нужно 10 минут ну давай 8 ты же не один поговори с человеком ты же можешь какой-то вести протокол
Можешь про себя не говорить, можешь дать возможность человеку 8 минут поговорить, они будут счастливы, а почему нет?
Нет, просто сказали, вынажьте свой способ, способ вынажается за приблизительно пару секунд.
Ну, наведи ситуацию, ну, Юр, ну, что ты такой сегодня скучный? Ну, чего ты всегда такой веселый такой, да, сегодня ты скучный, расскажи какую-нибудь историю, а потом расскажи, я игнорирую себя.
Ну вот, свяжи это всё с опытом и с историей.
Хорошо, благодарю.
Заставь антураж, драйв, расскажи что-то классное, и люди запомнят.
Да будет исторический момент в сегодняшнем дне,
когда мы расскажем какую-то интересную историю.
Давай, ну давай, не так все скучно.
А давайте вы нам пример покажете.
Ну как, я же тебе только что показала, я же тебе рассказала.
Да нет, в своей властной истории.
А что мне тут в моей истории?
Знаешь, сколько у меня, как Шахерезада могу сидеть здесь тебе рассказывать истории до завтра.
Но вам надо учиться.
Вот, хотя бы одну.
Посмотрим эту актерскую игру.
Мастерство передачи эмоций.
Юра, ты смотришь на мою актерскую игру 8 часов к ряду.
Минус 40 минут перерыва.
И так на протяжении уже 10 встречи.
Или 9.
А я не видела ни разу.
Сколько у меня внутреннего восторга.
Сейчас зайду и посмотрю, Юра, давай.
рассказывай историю придумывайте вспоминайте проблему ну это ж ваш сценарий не мой да я
просто знаю что очень часто когда люди они игнорируют себя это ты без конца игнорируешь
игнорируешь и потом ты себя не замечаешь это финальная расплата ужасно осознай изменить
Так, так, слушаю.
А, я думала, что вас нет.
Сейчас мы с Юлей
обработали в комнатах
игнорирование, да?
И у меня вышло
такое вопрос. Как разъяснить,
что игнорирование тут идет
с какой позиции,
а не с позиции эго?
То есть я тебя буду
игнорировать. Ну, я понимаю, что
ты и так не понимаешь, как я тебе буду объяснять, да?
Вот, например, мои отношения, так, мои отношения с мамой,
то есть там всегда у меня были отношения, что я потом взяла роль взрослого,
и вот мама, а где мама, а что ты про маму забыла, и что ты...
Вот мы эти этапы проживали.
Теперь я понимаю, что это ее схема, ей нужно выговориться,
и я не иду в объяснение, когда она задает эти вопросы,
я ожидаю там 3-4-5 минут, она вот выговорится,
мы потом про другую тему говорим своего рода это игнор себе то себе а себе тут это же беды
так тут на некрасивый шло одесс дырок может быть и здоровый игнор я поставки по я а ну здоровый
Здоровый игнор это выглядит так. Спасибо, мама, что ты мне говоришь, но у меня есть свои думки, я не буду 3 минуты тебя слушать, потому что у меня сегодня плохой день, например, да, это называется здоровый игнор, то есть здоровое контракт, здоровая разговора с мамой и здоровые такие отношения.
Добре. То есть игнорирование себя, когда я не отвечаю на себя и на это внимание. Игнорирование других, вот мама тут, возможно, игнорует вас, потому что она не отвечает на то, что с детьми вообще происходит. Это не всегда только нецензурные слова.
Игнорование ситуации, это когда человек, грандиозность этой прописки,
говорит, что у всех все нормально, только в нашей родине есть эта проблема.
И этот мир, он несправедливый.
Это понятно?
Первое. Игнорование вы поняли.
Идем дальше.
Почему я так остановилась?
Потому что мы сейчас перейдем к матрице этого игнорования.
Люди так живут.
Смотрите, дальше происходит изнецинение за типом.
То есть, человек не видит стимулов, не видит проблем и не видит возможностей.
То есть, Ира, если взять эту ситуацию с мамой,
извините, но я ее просто, как сейчас, наведу.
Мама не видит, або Юля не видит стимулов.
То есть, человек игнорирует стимулы. Она вообще выкресливает, что что-то вообще происходит. Она просто ла-ла-ла-ла-ла-ла-ла-ла-ла-ла-ла-ла-ла-ла-ла. То есть, сама игнорирует этот факт того, что что-то произошло.
Другое, да, игнорование за типом проблема.
Людина видит, что что-то происходит. Например, между нами есть дисконнекшн с мамой. У нас есть проблема. Мама не видит мои стимулы. У нас нет нормального общения в отношениях. Она видит проблему, но игнорует эту проблему.
Она говорит, у нас все нормально, все хорошо, мы просто так с тобой общались всю жизнь, ничего страшного нет. То есть, игнорирование проблемы. То есть, человек признает, что есть проблема, но игнорирует тот факт, что что-то происходит, что вообще эта проблема есть.
и игнорование
возможностей.
То есть, например, людина
видит, что есть проблема,
но
эта проблема есть,
но она говорит, что эту проблему
не можно решить.
Ну, такая мама, такая доля.
Это понятно?
Или нет?
Вот возьмите ту ситуацию,
которую вы только что обговорили
и подумайте
за типом, что
происходит. Людина, с которой
у вас есть проблема.
Она игнорует стимулы,
которые вы ей посылаете.
Она игнорует, что вообще есть проблема.
Или она игнорует
возможность ее решения.
Я понятно вам рассказываю
сейчас, да, этот тип, или нет?
Да, да, но и намного сложнее,
что в моменте не задавало
себя.
Хорошо. Пожалуйста, еще на 6 минут в те же пары.
Можно предыдущий слайд на 1 минуту?
Можно. Можно, Василий.
Пожалуйста, держи.
Людина не видит стимулов, не видит проблем и не видит возможности решения этой проблемы.
Добре. Тут зрозуміло за типом. Шо, хто, хто, хто, в кого, шо, игнорую. Частіше за все.
У мене тройничок. Одне тяне, друге и третє.
Добре. Тобто, у тебе знову джекпот. Сьогодні, так, в кого, шо, ще?
джек-пот да будет какого потенцию матрица доводится на скажи ну я понял что я могу
не могу сказать что прям адаптируюсь но все равно это зависит от обстоятельств и кто и
что и как и все три имеет место быть ну когда есть вопрос официантов например даже проиграл
остаться социантами, я всегда вижу
мою эмпатию
и сонострой, я вижу, как
человек, если он испуганный
сам и говорит, да, красиво,
то я на себя в этот момент, я говорю,
так возможно, и такое может быть,
случится с каждым, ну, то есть, типа, как бы
даже включаю такое, чтобы он,
грубо говоря, даже его
утешать, да, игнорируя свои
в этот момент стимулы, что у меня там вообще
шок-контент.
Ты сидишь вся мокрая, платье красивое
дело, а у тебя кофе на этом
платье, образно говоря, понимаешь,
моя девочка? Никто не умер, да,
в этот момент, и он испуганный.
Если я вижу, что в этот момент, понимаете,
он еще даже села, тут расселась,
не пройти кофе, не пронести,
ну, я образно, если на меня с такой
реакцией, то я, конечно, включаю,
собрала, опустила, и
ничего, что я, блядь, сижу тут такая красивая
в платье, и вся
обляпанная, добрый вечер.
Вот. Но, как бы,
и нет такого, чтобы кого-то
оскорблять. А так, что там, типа,
почему это со мной? Это может произойти
как угодно. Тут
зависимость и еще реакция человека.
Но первый момент я всегда, как бы,
для стабилизации. Ну, такое может быть,
да. И такое тоже может быть.
Да, и это очень важно понять,
что у нас есть с любимыми топиками.
Это еще не все.
И теперь третий процесс.
Очень важный, да, потому что вы потом
сможете тоже, в принципе, это все
анализировать с вашими клиентами.
Показываю.
И изнецинение за ревным.
То есть, первое за областью, второе за типом, третье за ревным.
То есть, есть четыре ревные изнецинения.
Знецинение, существование, проблемы.
Например, человек пишет с ошибками, и он может сказать, что знецинение, существование, проблемы, не важно, как я пишу, важно, что я пишу.
Важно не формат, а именно смысл.
Второе, знецинение, значит, что эти проблемы.
Ой, помылки – это моя вечная проблема, не обратите на это внимания.
Знецинение возможностей измен.
Я не думаю, что нужно перевчаться, у меня уже нет на это времени.
И знецинение своих возможностей.
Мне уже не нужно перевчаться, я никогда не научусь писать без помылок.
Подумайте про себя.
И что именно вы оцениваете?
Иснование проблемы, значащиеся проблемы,
возможности измен, или свои возможности.
Снова на 6 минут.
так так на слуху у нас раз на ком-то раскидывать значащие еще раз значащая
приуменьшаю до проблемы свою или ситуацию которая произошла сейчас покажу честное смотри
вот слайд сделай себе скрин гонял на лице не
это самое сложное в этой теме да получается что
она больше будет приводить к этой матрице обесценивания
сложный вопрос очень сложно
Какой-то уже легче говорить про объяснение, когда мы уже говорим третью
годину про него, то какой-то нормально. Нормально, да, не так страшно. Настя, скажи.
Чем глубже мы поныриваемся туда в объяснении, тем больше я вижу, что я могу вообще, это что,
адаптация? Не могу сказать, что это адаптация. Оно по-разному проигрывается, в зависимости от
ситуация того что произошло где есть что как в каком вообще как это но я никогда не через
чувства все равно через действия видите никогда не говори мне так обидно ли там у меня так
расстроилась я все через действия вижу все человек ну сам испугался вот будут сам человек из что-то
произошло он сам испугался лужа и облили да и он сам испугался но этаж его персональная проблема
что он испугался ну так а затянуло что в этот момент сидеть продавливать его дальше на просто
здесь очень важно понять где какие у нас способы есть реагирование на этот мир мы кричали всевозможные
могу и так и так и так отреагировать и тут это вот надо настюша понять есть проблема к чему эта
проблема приведет какая будет финальная расплата зачем я вам это все вещая уже который день до и
и который сегодня час, про это обесценивание.
Подумайте, пожалуйста, какая будет финальная расплата
при использовании каждого этого способа реагирования на ситуацию.
Разносторонняя.
Ну, например, игнорирование себя, болезнь.
Болезнь.
Не дай Боже, умрёшь там от чего-то не очень хорошего.
Игнорирование других, одиночество,
потому что ты, игнорируя потребности других людей, ты останешься один.
Игнорирование вообще мира, да, ты будешь в своей пассивности жить свою жизнь
и рассказывать, боже, какой мир мне справедливый, как мне дальше со всем этим быть.
У тебя не будет никаких рычагов воздействия.
Не видишь стимулы, да, зачем я это всё вам рассказываю,
потому что вначале идёт вот этот вот кусочек, что мы игнорируем,
а потом мы начинаем анализировать, что мы, блин, не видим, мы не видим стимулы, что нам люди говорят, да, мы их вообще не замечаем, мы не видим проблему, ну, такие мы слепые, всё у нас, вообще ничего не заметно, нет проблемы, ну, так родители ведут себя, или возможности её решить, а потом уже начинается вот эта комбинация, размышления, почему я не могу решить эту проблему,
Что я проигнорировала?
Я не замечаю, что эта проблема влияет на мою жизнь.
Я не замечаю, что у меня есть рычаги влияния на эту проблему.
Я не замечаю, что вообще моя жизнь, она может измениться.
И это всё будет дальше таким вашим диагностическим инструментом,
когда вот это вот вы галочки поставите,
сейчас я вам покажу матрицу обесценивания,
и вы поймёте, что вам надо делать.
Влад, знаете, в этой истории чего-то лично мне не хватает?
Где-то какого-то позитива, как-то всё печально и грустно.
Настюша, я вам сейчас, Настя, отвечу, какой позитив.
Осознание проблемы ведёт к её изменениям.
Ты до этого долгую жизнь жила, даже сегодня в начале семинара ты мне рассказала,
все отлично. Влада, бунтую.
Вообще ничего с семьей
связанного нет.
Настя, заканчивается семинар.
И это
с семьей связано. И вот эта
ситуация зафонила. И вот это
есть. И понимание
есть, к чему же это приведет.
А самое главное, мы это осознав,
мы будем же это менять.
Настя.
Менять, да. Вопрос на что
менять, да? Вот тут где это?
Где это?
баланс которому мы идем качаете ли туда и сюда так это ты же не может как жонглёр баланс выдерживать
вот этот можешь настя можешь как-то выдерживала все эти годы и дальше сможешь но по-другому
решим этот вопрос сейчас дальше покажу эту матрицу снежанка
Думка пришла, две думки. Первая, мы же имеем дело с клиентами, да, и они берут на себя, ну, обязательно эту деятельность, и мы потом иногда с ними бьемся, уже исследуем, а почему же они не выполнили, или так далее.
А тут тоже очень много ответов, потому что, возможно, есть неценение себя, возможности, как вы говорите, да, или света, или человека, то есть вот эти вещи, это классно.
И второе, у меня такая мысль возникла, мы говорили с вами на последний раз, мне кажется, ну и вообще эта тема, типа я окей, ты окей, это такая самая здоровейшая позиция, да, взрослая.
И вот это оценивание очень сильно себя, если я не окей, а кто-то окей, то тогда это будет оценивание себя, оценивание возможностей решить ситуацию и так далее, и так далее.
Тогда это всегда будет официант, ну, Настя, извините, такой грубо взляканный, и я не говорю, что в Насте это я не окей,
но там кто-то всегда будет там, ой, меня облили, меня обматюкали, тут он измученный, тут он взляканный, тут он еще какой-то,
потому что я не окей, а он, в принципе, окей.
Да, потому что это связано и с жизненной позицией тоже, да, то есть к чему людина привыкла.
Так я окей, я при этом...
И окей.
в одном кафе если он как бы мне не понравилось блюдо я им говорю вы что-то сделали то в прошлый
раз был вкусно в этот раз какой-то соус я не могу это есть это невкусно он забирает но включает в
счет я могу вы окей я окей я про проплатила и сказала больше сюда не приду почему потому что
вот так вот так вот так и чтобы там что они при этом не ok но это их выбор ну все я рассчиталась
ушла это тоже мы а в другом кафе мне говорит все забирается счет и даже не включает ну ну
невкусно я скажу об этом но ну там но если он начинает мне хамить в этот момент ну типа шо
всегда так делали ли еще что-то я говорю что нет это не нормально и я не вижу в этом нормы
и трата то я тоже начинаю объяснять но просто и они окей поступки бывают люди всегда все окей
и они ok я ok просто бывают поступки неподходящие да не очень поступки у людей но это теперь а теперь
чтоб мы успели мы успели нам надо эту матрицу рассмотреть смотрите за эту матрицу вообще шифы
получили премию река берна то есть они взяли создали такую табличку по которой анализировали
профиль других людей они создали матрицу которая помогает разобраться где у клиента есть какой-то
процесс обесценивания где у него есть какая-то проблема я вам ее за раз покажу тю матрицу
почтим узнай а против от и одразу с прикладом и давится молюте такая табличка табличка в на вас
Есть табличка снежинок, да? Добре. Есть здесь способ, а здесь есть тип. И вот сверху, вот здесь, видите,
Т1, Т2, Т3, Т2, Т3, Т4, Т3, Т4, Т5, Т4, Т5, Т6.
Сверху вот тут есть такие штуки.
Есть способ и тип.
Что мы тут видим? Т1.
Когда клиент запрещает сам факт стимула.
То есть клиент приходит к нам и говорит, что я много работаю.
Или этого вообще не видит.
То есть, например, клиент запрещает, что он много работает и что он выслушивается.
То есть он не видит стимула, что работа приведет его к могиле.
Т-2. Знеценение значимости стимулов или существования проблемы.
Тут стимул, тут проблема.
Клиент говорит, что я много работаю, но проблем в этом нет.
Нет проблемы.
Тут он запрещает, что он много работает, что он выслуживается.
Тут он говорит, что я работаю, но не признает этого выслуживания, не имеет проблемы.
Далее. Знеценение стимула значимости проблемы на явности вариантов выбора.
Клиент говорит, клиент признает, что он выснаживается,
но говорит, что работа ему нравится, и все так живут, и что это нормально.
Эта штука поняла? Т1, Т2, Т3.
Давайте по вашим ситуациям напишите, пожалуйста, Т1, Т2, Т3.
Ну, так вот и надо написать все сразу, Настя.
Ну, например, пишем в Т1.
Есть проблема, но я вообще не вижу, что она есть.
Но в данном случае это реально работающий кейс.
Клиент, бизнес-клиент, SEO-компания вечно без конца работает.
пришел к вам считать что проблемы нет но вы видите черные круги под глазами вы видите что
у него нет никаких отношений вы видите что он страдает он заработал миллиарды секси лярдов
миллионов но проблемы нет что конкретно он игнорирует что конкретно каждый из
вас игнорирует? Что каждый из вас игнорирует в этом? Занотуйте T1, T2, T3. Сейчас еще раз покажу.
Сделайте фото, кстати. Это очень классная штука.
Будет потом застык с какими-то клиентами, вы будете сидеть и думать, да, в чём моя история.
Смотрите, в чём моя интересность.
Если клиент игнорирует проблему вот здесь, то по диагонали он игнорирует значимость стимулей.
Вот, например, еще раз, еще раз, дивись, вот у нас есть пример, клиент много работает, да,
Понятно, да, SEO-компания.
Первый, Т1, он игнорирует стимул.
То есть он, видишь, он запрещает, что он выснаживается и что он много работает.
Мы знаем, если он много работает, он умрет.
Далее, второе, он говорит, да, я много работаю, но не вижу в этом проблемы.
Я не выснаживаюсь, как проблема.
Тут он игнорует варианты выбора.
И как мы ликуем эту людину?
Мы находим, где в нее завтык.
Тут, тут или тут.
Если он игнорует проблему,
говорит, что я много работаю, но нет вынуждения.
Это означает, что вот здесь, в этой матрице, нужно делать такие штучки по диагонали.
Смотрите.
И ты по диагонали.
Диагональ влево или диагональ вправо?
Тоже может быть.
Сейчас я тебе покажу.
Вот так.
Поняли?
То есть, если он не видит проблемы, видит Т2, и здесь Т2, это он игнорирует значимость стимулов, он вообще не видит стимулы, и ему нужно объяснить, что это тебя вбьет.
Далее, смотрите, Т3 – варианты выбора.
В человеке он говорит, что все так живут,
но работа ему нравится.
Он может игнорировать значимость проблемы.
Он не понимает, что эта проблема может быть очень значимой.
Т3, видите, Т3 и тут Т3.
Далее я вам буду показывать это.
Все мои, все так много работали, не видели другого жизни.
И он не видит альтернативы, потому что он говорит, что всё, жизнь, она такая.
Скажи, Снежана, скажи.
Да, да. А чем вы отличаетесь тогда от Т3?
Потому что там тоже клиент говорит, что все так живут, и это нормально.
Вот в чем тут разница?
Смотри, тут клиент признает, что выслушивается, но говорит, что работа ему нравится.
А в Т4 он признает, что много работает, выслушивается, и уже работа не нравится.
Это забирает энергию.
Он понимает, что он очень зависимый.
Но он говорит, что мой папа так работал, мой дед так работал.
И я не знаю, как работать по-другому, потому что вся моя семья работала с утра до ночи.
Понимаешь? То есть на этом уровне вот такое совсем неосознанное, что есть проблема, что есть какие-то стимулы, что есть какие-то варианты.
Людмила живет своей жизнью. А тут дальше уже начинается какая-то значимость.
Он понимает, что что-то у меня так не мочится, что-то у меня не очень хорошо в этом жизни.
Т4. Т5. Знецинение властной издатности вырешивать проблему
или изменивать варианты выбора.
Клиент признает, что много работает, что выснаживается, что это проблема,
но не видит других вариантов и не верит, что что-то может измениться
и остается в этой работе.
Вот видите, Т5. И тут, если мы по диагонали рисуем эту штуку, он не оценивает собственную возможность решить эту проблему. Он говорит, что это невозможно изменить. Но кто его изменит, если не он?
То есть он остается на этой работе, он не далегует эту работу другим людям, он работает, работает, остается на работе, уничтожает родину, но он работает, блин, он остается там, он не идет с работы, он не изменяет свой расклад, он не изменяет ничего.
И тут вообще идем к Т6, то есть связанный с запрещением своей собственной способности использовать возможности выбора.
Клиент говорит, что я вообще ничего в этом жизни изменить не смогу.
Тут становится более понятно?
Оно так, но хочется тогда спросить, что делать с Т1 и Т6.
То есть, тут эти, по крайней мере, куда-то ведут,
а эти два, они не имеют никакого отношения дальше.
Смотри, Т1, ты ему объясняешь, что это и есть проблема.
Есть стимулы, которые на него влияют.
То есть, что есть какая-то ситуация, ты ее проговоришь заместо него, Василий.
Ты человеку говоришь, смотри, вот это, вот это, вот это, это и есть стимул.
А в Т6 ты говоришь, какая будет финальная расплата, если ничего в твоем жизни не изменится.
И дальше в него идет осознание, что если он не изменится, он умрет и его похоронят в очень богатой труне.
Понимаешь?
То есть чем все закончится? Это же он так заканчивает на Т.
Чем заканчивается твое жизнь? Для чего ты сюда пришел? Что ты сделал? Ну хорошо, все будут радоваться.
Я не знаю, какая-то корпорация будет квитнуть, у тебя деньги будут.
Нафига тебе деньги и тот миллиардный счет, если у тебя нет дальше жизни?
Да, потому что наша задача, этот баланс, до этого доводить людей, чтобы люди могли жить, а не работать только без конца.
без конца. Как вам эта история с матрицей? То есть мы практически проводим не просто
вопросами, а уже вопрос идет только первым, а дальше мы уже проводим грубо говоря, как психологи,
не так как коучи, вопросами по этой ситуации, дающие какие-то фидбэки, да? Да, да, а это и есть
коучинг. Ты также знаешь, твоя задача коуча конфронтировать человека в том, что она делает не то.
мать и на цену подводит и его питанием заразь я вам покажу эти питания снежин давайте зараз а
потом я питание покажу то что не так пошла налоги назначая право члены право уже матрицею делся
повязано ну так до всяких моментах и а идентичный снег или вверить мне не просто крохи по-иншему там
про ценности. А тут мы
смотрим про проблему.
Что человека игнорирует?
Она не видит, что там
есть какой-то дисконнекшн
с разговором. Она игнорирует себя,
потому что привыкла так себя поводить.
Что вообще происходит?
Дело 100%
Что, Настя, скажи?
Хорошо.
Когда человек на своем собственном
опыте прожил,
понимает, что может сыграть
в ящик и так уже знает как к чему это приводит уже получил свой опыт и теперь появился страх
что и сейчас начнешь опять ну куда-то все про нет вот этого баланса да еще не выстроена как
это колесо баланса там да где берут кучу не в панели то и появляется страх что-то делать
потому что знаешь что ты можешь уже ты знаешь уже чем расплату вот как тогда если ты понимаешь свою
финальную расплату что ты хочешь изменить и здесь очень важно сесть и для самого себя описать четко
мои ожидания что я хочу изменить настя многие люди они не находят времени чтобы отрефлексировать
самим собой как выглядит моя идеальная жизнь я не говорю сейчас про вот эти красивые картинки
да там про идеальных клиентов семью про идеальные отношения я говорю про реальность да что я хочу
получить для своей жизни хорошего в чем моя радость и вот если я сяду и начну думать какую
я радостную жизнь тебе хочу тогда у меня появится радость и она будет преобладать над страхом и
тогда у меня будет высокий уровень мотивации идти к своей радостной жизни они просто знаете работы
ведь это то что закрывает часто дыры других людей пустоту алкоголь и наркотики секс и
работа покупки это то что закрывает безумные дыры в дефиците нашей любви почему человек
работает бесконечно потому что у него есть потребность любви он ее не получает вместо
того чтобы эту любовь найти он идет и получает это через работу работа это любовницы или любовники да
тогда есть вопрос тогда вопросу когда ты говоришь найди свою работу которая приносит тебе радость и
ты не будешь работать ни одного дня вот на этом люди спотыкаются очень сильно потому что по факту
работает и все равно остается работой я работа приносила радость это ложь это убеждение это
Это загрязнение, это контоминация.
Работа наша бывает разной.
Работа бывает, как и жизнь.
Она бывает и радостной, и тяжёлой.
Вчера в начале дня я думала, что всё, мне будет капец.
Мне спрашивали люди, как я.
Я думала, всё, смерть ко мне пришла.
Это невозможно, это невозможно.
Это худший день из моих худших дней, худшее утро.
Но в конце дня, когда ты увидел человека,
я о себе сейчас говорю,
например подростка который слава богу не совершил суицид вовремя прибежал к своим родителям сказал
своей маме и когда ты увидел что все хорошо это уже радует понимаете и ты понимаешь что твоя
работа она бывает разным бывает грустно и бывает радостно но это жизнь и не надо рассказывать вот
эти трепетные истории про работу которая должна приносить удовольствие идите занимайтесь прудзале
24 часа на 7 я хочу посмотреть на ваше удовольствие надо иметь баланс поэтому я
вот вам сегодня вещаю как радио свобода да пожалуйста обратите что вы игнорируете и
конечно в эту матрицу не сразу можно въехать это какой-то но иногда я думаю боже люди как
вы зато как вы замутили в этом транзактном она я вам честно говорю я иногда просто вот не могла
понять что они хотят а потом со временем поняла что они хотели донести они хотели донести что
ты в своей жизни игнорируешь стимулы проблему или возможности и разрешения вот это самое главное
разберись что ты игнорируешь и дальше это измене добрый давайте вам за распитание покажу реки можно
задавать и клиентам чтобы она просто так вот всю матрицу были на загале на из разумеющего
что вы от него хотите, да, смотрите, есть у нас для того, чтобы помочь выозначить вот этот Т1 уровень.
На этом уровне исследуется, что признает человек сам факт того, что происходит. Типовые
вопросы, что случилось, чего вы потребуете, что вы чувствуете, о чем вы думаете, что вы делаете,
чего вы хотите. То есть таким образом мы признаем, что есть стимулы. Далее Т2, выозначение проблемы.
На этом уровне проверяется, или человек признает, что в ней произошло, что есть проблема, и что есть, и это имеет значение.
Типовые вопросы.
Или то, что вы описали, есть проблемой для вас?
Насколько для вас это важно?
Или вообще это мешает вам жить?
Или достигать желания?
И Т3. Вызначение способов вырешения.
Чи може шось бути инакше?
Наскільки для вас важлива ця проблема?
Чи важлива про те, що ми з вами говорили раніше про стимулы?
Чи бачите ви взагалі це як проблему, з якою шось можна зробити?
То есть нам нужно просто задать вопрос и понимать, на каком уровне происходит это изнасилование.
Потому что тогда человек начнет осознавать.
Т4. Вызначение меты.
То есть мы ищем, способны ли вы реагировать по-другому,
Чи вырешуется ця проблема?
Чи мають
відношення до вырешення
цієї проблеми? Чи є якісь
варіанты?
Щось ми можемо змінити? Яка в нас мета?
Т-5.
Визначення перешкод.
Питання, чи здатні
ви вырешувати
проблеми та
ну, домогаться
долгостроковых измен.
Т6.
Вызначение
возможностей диеты. Чем можете
вы застосовать этот способ
для решения вашей проблемы таким
образом, чтобы она была решена?
Такие вопросы.
Снежан, скажи.
В смысле слуха. Я подумала, что
часть этих вопросов,
я бы их формулировала там не «чьи»,
они все такие да, да, да. Можно включать в эту диагностическую сессию, когда приходит клиент,
касательно этого запроса на диагностическую сессию, можно уже понимать больше, как строить этот мейд мэп,
как работать с клиентом, в зависимости от того, что он там оценивает, или себя, или варианты, или этот стимул,
и это дает много информации для работы.
Да, да, и нужно просто понимать, можно ничем, можно как-то по-другому, как вам удобнее.
Как вы хотите, так и делайте. Но смотрите, если подсуммировать, в Т1 нам нужно осознать, что есть какие-то стимулы. В Т2 нам нужно осознать, что есть проблема.
В Т3 нам нужно осознать, что есть возможности изменений.
В Т4 осознание, что мы сами можем изменивать эту проблему.
Мы можем что-то сделать, именно сделать, Настя, то, что ты делаешь, сделать.
Т-4. Т-5. Мы можем осознать, что у нас есть возможность выбора.
И в Т-6 осознать, что только я отвечаю за свое жизнь, и только я могу решить эту проблему.
Скажи, Василий.
Так тут выглядит, что первая и вторая, в принципе, доступны относительно всех.
большинство клиентов с этим согласится, а уже третья, четвертая, пятая, шестая, это уже типа где-то
высшего порядка, большая осознанность людей, которые готовы действительно расширяться, а не просто
топтаться на месте. Да, так оно и есть. И это очень важно. Слушайте, мои любимые друзья, а что, Снежин,
А я думаю, что меня напомнило. Мне это напомнило транс-теоретическую модель изменений. Там тоже шесть этапов, и они очень много в чем-то перегукиваются.
А я же тебе говорю, какого года эта транс-генератичная модель изменений?
Я тут вот скоро в GPT, скажу, дай мне короску.
Якого вона року?
Зараз вам скажет.
Бо я читала...
Рик, рик, рик який.
Бо я читала недавно про це дело,
и воно мне дуже лягло.
Там пчела с клиенткою уже одно це використовате.
Ну не каже вона, блин, не каже.
Вон что-ли дурно.
Якого року воно?
Я потім напишу, добро, якого року,
бо шось він слухає мене и...
Ага.
70-80-х годов, пока 70-80-е годы. Джеймс про Хаск и Карло Ди Кламенто.
Очень хорошо, да. То есть, видишь, они шли и разработали эти концепции почти параллельно, да, потому что ШИФы, они больше активировались в 1973 году.
То есть, на пановение какое-то такое было, которое подхапливало в разных позициях?
Может, я не знаю. Я не знаю, что. То есть, это такой метод, и он тогда разработался, и очень классно они его дальше рассматривали.
Кстати, именно за это, за эту матрицу они получили эту премию. Она прикольная, она классная, она интересная, потому что она позволяет очень быстро работать с клиентами.
Давайте сегодня посмотрим, что мы с вами изучили.
Кстати, сегодня был очень важный, очень наполненный семинар.
Мы с вами поговорили про пассивную поведенку, много говорили.
Про то, как воспринимаем свет и про сценарии говорили.
Про перевозначение и какие патологические процессы, как люди это делают.
Про симбиоз, как люди формуют пассивность.
Про здоровый и нездоровый симбиоз.
в какие формы есть симбиозы, кто за счет платит, а кто лялечкой будет.
И поговорили про матрицу знецинения.
У меня есть для вас домашка.
Взять эту матрицу, ну что вы сильно смотрите так.
Ну не успели мы это сделать.
Взять эту матрицу знецинения, которая у вас есть,
и просто с интересом посмотреть и запомнить ее.
То есть, как она запомнилась, в каждом квадратике можно что-то записать. Что я не вижу, что вижу.
Ну, посмотреть, проанализировать свою поведение.
Мы же, в принципе, каждые 6 секунд это и делали.
А теперь взять и это все вписать. Или взять еще один прикольный пример. Например, отношения.
Подивитесь, что я не ценю в отношениях, стимулы, проблемы или возможность выбора.
Что кого драйвить, то и пройдите еще раз.
Скажите, что вам сегодня понравилось, у нас 10 минут на завершение.
Что заберете с собой, мои хорошие?
Перевестки мои.
Нормально так звучит?
Что заберете с собой?
даже на говори шоу глубокие сессии больше 50 минут и нельзя проходить зато транзакционный
анализ влады можно пройти 6 часов я иногда вот понимаю знаете вы взяли такую тему сложно и даже
поняли вот этот вот кусочек да что я вам хотела донести очень тяжело понять я долго могла понять
что они за что они премию получили вообще не понимала так что наша выдержка день молодцы
я горжусь вами и вы меняетесь до василька же ну говорю говорю буду говорить один знает крутейших
уроки в загале за все мсм сегодня и и особистому их припрачиваем особистому их триггеров моих точек
зон росту прям охуенно дякую я рада шо вам шось заходит дивится в кожного будэ сви семинар він
будэ для нього відгукуватися більше бо в кожного з вас своє методи будуть робота але будь ласка
послідкуйтесь за ціми симбиозами як ви створювати шо робити і взагалі просто нічого не робіть більше
зайвого. Втомилися, мои котятки, гении мои, разумнички, да, тоже втомилися, у вас еще пара будет, да,
как всегда. Ну что, мои хорошие, идите, 10 минут вам отдыха дам, даже 8. Отпочивайте, я вас
обожаю, обнимаю, кто обнимается, кто не обнимается, так же поруч все. Бережите себя, на связку.